नाउ
ओके
ओके आई एम लाइव नाउ राइट 3 मिनट लेट हो
गया मैं आई हैव कम 3 मिनट्स लेट
एक्सट्रीमली सॉरी फॉर दैट एवरीबॉडी गुड
इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग गुड इवनिंग एंड नमस्ते
टू सभी को
गुड इवनिंग एंड नमस्ते टू एवरीबडी
ओके हेलो हेलो हेलो हेलो चलिए काफी लोग
यहां पे ऑलरेडी जुड़ चुके हैं। काफी लोग
अभी और भी आ रहे हैं। तो सबको एक बार आ
जाने देते हैं। एंड वेलकम टू द क्लास 22
ऑफ दिस एसओसी एल वन जॉब रेडी फ्री लाइव
ट्रेनिंग जो अपने आप में एक यूनिक फ्री
ट्रेनिंग है जो जो कि आपको जॉब रेडी बनाती
है एसओसी एल1 प्रोफाइल के लिए। एंड आई होप
कि आप इस ट्रेनिंग को काफी ज्यादा एंजॉय
कर रहे हैं। राइट?
ओके।
चलिए। सो
या लाइक ठोक दिया। बहुत अच्छी बात है।
लाइक ठोक दिया तो अच्छी बात है। बहुत
बढ़िया।
सभी आ जाते हैं जल्दी से फटाफट। एंड वी
विल बी स्टार्टिंग। एंड आज की टॉपिक आपको
पता चल ही गया होगा कि बहुत ही ज्यादा एक
इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक है जिसका नाम है एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरी। एंड बेसिकली ये टॉपिक एक ये
एक यूनिवर्सल टॉपिक आप बोल सकते हो साइबर
सिक्योरिटी डोमेन में मैं तो यही बोलूंगा
दिस इज़ अ काइंड ऑफ़ यूनिवर्सल टॉपिक।
यूनिवर्सल टॉपिक का मतलब यह होता है कि
जितने भी टॉप लेवल के सर्टिफिकेशंस हैं
साइबर सिक्योरिटी में जिनके नाम आप जानते
होंगे मोस्टली उन सब में इस टॉपिक से
रिलेटेड क्वेश्चंस जनरली आपको मिल जाएंगे।
ठीक है? इसके आसपास के इसके इर्द-गिर्द के
क्वेश्चंस, इससे डायरेक्ट इससे क्वेश्चंस
वो सब आपको ऑलमोस्ट मिल जाएंगे। राइट? तो
आपको ये जो टॉपिक है वो इस इस तरीके से
समझनी है जैसे कि दिस इज़ वन ऑफ़ द मोस्ट
इंपॉर्टेंट टॉपिक नॉट जस्ट फॉर एसओसी बट
फॉर ओवरऑल साइबर सिक्योरिटी डोमेन। साइबर
सिक्योरिटी के मल्टीपल डोमेनस में ये आपकी
हेल्प करता है। ये आपकी बेसिकली आपके लिए
यूज़फुल रहेगा एंड आपको मजा आएगा मल्टीपल
डोमेनस में। ठीक है? जस्ट अ सेकंड थोड़ी
सी चेयर को ऊपर करनी पड़ेगी मुझे हम नाउ द
हाइट इज परफेक्ट आई थिंक हाइट अब सही हो
गई है चेयर वाली अ
या आई थिंक आई एम नाउ एट परफेक्ट
हाइट पोजीशन ठीक है चलिए ठीक है नाउ डन सो
एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी के आप में से पहले एक
बार बता दीजिए गुलूग्लू इवनिंग गुलगुल
इवनिंग एक बार आप लोग सभी लोग बता दीजिए
कि एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी के बारे में आप
लोगों में से कितने लोग पहले पहले से
जानते हैं। हाउ मेनी ऑफ़ यू नो अबाउट
एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी? अ ऑलरेडी कितने लोग
पहले से जानते हैं? जस्ट लेट मी नो। एक
बार बता दीजिए फटाफट।
कुछ लोगों को कुछ लोगों को पता होगा शायद।
एक बार बताइए जल्दी सभी लोग बताइए एक बार।
एवरीवन
एवरीवन प्लीज लेट मी नो।
बालों की बैंड बज गई है। चलो और बताओ। ठीक
है। ठीक है।
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
कई लोगों को पता है। कई लोगों को नहीं पता
है। ठीक है। कोई बात नहीं है। लेट्स
स्टार्ट। आज के बहुत मजा मजे आएंगे आपको।
आपको एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी इतना इजी वे में
मैं आपको समझाऊंगा। इतना इजी वे में मैं
आपको सिखाऊंगा। जितना ईजी वे में आपने आज
तक एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी जो है अह नहीं सीखा
होगा या ऐसे इतना इजी वे में आप कभी
सीखेंगे भी नहीं। ठीक है? इतना इजी वे में
मैं आपको बताने वाला हूं। बस थोड़ा आज के
सेशन पे ध्यान देना है। थोड़ा कंसंट्रेशन
ज्यादा रखना है। क्योंकि चीजें थोड़ी सी
आपको लगेंगी कि अ
समझ नहीं आ रहा है। बट जब आप ध्यान से
कंसंट्रेट होके इस चीज को जब गैब करेंगे
तो आपको सब समझ में आ जाएगा। एंड इतनी इजी
वे में समझाऊंगा जितना इजी वे आपको जनरली
कहीं नहीं देखने को मिलेगा। राइट? सो
लेट्स स्टार्ट। उसके पहले आपको सबसे पहला
जो है वो काम क्या करना है? सिंपल सा
सिंपल सा काम है कि कोई सी भी जैसे
डिफ्रॉनिक्स एकडमी आपको ओपन कर लेनी है।
कोई सी भी एसओसी की लाइव ट्रेनिंग में आना
है। प्रीवियस एसओसी की वीडियो आपको ओपन कर
लेनी है। एंड ओपन करने के बाद आपको
डिस्क्रिप्शन को एक्सपेंड करना है। और
यहां पे दो आपको लिंक्स मिलेंगे। पहला एंड
दूसरा पहला लिंक हमारा जो है WhatsApp
चैनल का लिंक है जो कि आप इस लिंक पे
जाएंगे जो एक एक लिंक आपको WhatsApp चैनल
का मिलेगा और एक WhatsApp ग्रुप का
मिलेगा। तो WhatsApp चैनल का जो लिंक है
डिफ्रॉनिक्स AC एकडमी नाम से होगा जहां
13,000 डिफ़्रॉनिक्सर्स हमारे साथ है। यहां
सबसे पहले आपको कोई भी नोटिफिकेशन हमारी
तरफ से मिलेगी। ओवरऑल वो सबसे पहले आपको
इसी चैनल पे मिलेगा। कहीं भी और नहीं
मिलेगा। इस चैनल पे मिलेगा। तो इसको फॉलो
कर लीजिएगा। फ्री में आपको फॉलो करने को
फ्री में कर सकते हो। कोई पैसा नहीं देना
है। दूसरा जो लिंक होगा वह एक और लिंक वो
WhatsApp ग्रुप का होगा जो एसओसी के लिए
स्पेशल ग्रुप बनाया गया है। एसओ से
रिलेटेड जितने रिसोर्सेज होते हैं इसी
ग्रुप में इन्हीं जो ग्रुप्स हैं उनमें
शेयर किए जाते हैं। इससे
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] रिलेटेड जो
भी अपडेट्स होते हैं इसी में आपको आएंगे।
अपकमिंग सर्टिफिकेशन इसके रिगार्डिंग
अपकमिंग इंटरव्यू प्रिपरेशन सब कुछ इसी
में मिलने वाला है। यानी जो भी चीजें हैं
आपको इस ग्रुप में एसओसी की मिलने वाली
है। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] ये
Lindin प्रोफाइल है मेरी। आप इस पे आके
मुझे फॉलो कर सकते हैं। मुझसे कनेक्ट हो
सकते हैं यहां पे एंड मुझसे इंटरेक्ट कर
सकते हैं। ठीक है? साथ ही में अभी आप
पोस्ट पे जाएंगे तो याद रखिएगा यह Lindin
पोस्ट जो मैंने किया हुआ है 50,000
सब्सक्राइबर सेलिब्रेशन का। सबसे पहले तो
आप सभी को भी मेनी मेनी कांग्रेचुलेशंस
दैट वी रीच्ड 50,000 सब्सक्राइबर मार्क्स।
एंड दिस इज़ वन ऑफ़ द अह वन ऑफ़ द ग्रेटेस्ट
अचीवमेंट फॉर दिस डिफ़ॉन Academy YouTube
चैनल। क्योंकि द फर्स्ट थिंग कि ये पहला
माइलस्टोन है। तो ये काफी इंपॉर्टेंट है।
इंपॉर्टेंट होता है हमारे लिए। एंड आप
सबकी मदद से आप सबकी हेल्प से आप सबके
सपोर्ट, प्यार एंड यह रेगुलर जो आपने आप
जो ट्रस्ट दिखाते हो उसकी हेल्प से ही यह
अचीवमेंट जो है हम अचीव कर पाए हैं इस
माइलस्टोन को। तो इस पोस्ट पे जो यह पोस्ट
है इसको आप इस पे आप आ सकते हैं टू
पार्टिसिपेट इन द गिव अवे। जिनको नहीं पता
मैं आपको लेट्स सपोज अगर आपको नहीं पता
मैं आपको बता देता हूं। YouTube चैनल जो
है डिफ्रॉनिक्स का हमारा
बेसिकली इफ यू विल गो टू द YouTube चैनल
ऑफ़ आवर डेफोनिक्स एकडमी देन यहां पे
फिलहाल के लिए
वीडियोस पे जब आप जाएंगे तो यहां एक गिव
अवे की वीडियो है। वन वीक का इसका डेडलाइन
है। दो दिन पहले यह वीडियो डली हुई थी।
यहां पे काफी लोगों ने इसमें पार्टिसिपेट
करा है। इस वीडियो को पूरा देख लीजिएगा।
इस गिव अवे में पार्टिसिपेट कर सकते हैं
क्योंकि इस गिव अवे में कुछ हम ब्लंडर ऑफर
कर रहे हैं। बहुत ही बड़ी चीज ऑफर कर रहे
हैं। क्या ऑफर कर रहे हैं मैं आपको बता
देता हूं। mfronic.com वीएपीटी पे जब आप
जाएंगे तो यहां पे हमारे हमारे हमारी
वीएपीटी की जो ट्रेनिंग होती है जो कि एक
कंप्लीट ट्रूली जॉब ओरिएंटेड ट्रेनिंग है।
लास्ट बैच से 10 बच्चों की प्लेसमेंट हुई
थी। यही ट्रेनिंग टॉप थ्री के जो जो गिव
अवे के विनर्स होंगे उनको बिल्कुल फ्री
एक्सेस दिया जाएगा। ₹1 चार्ज नहीं किया
जाएगा। किसी भी स्टेज पे ट्रेनिंग के किसी
भी तरीके से बिल्कुल फ्री दिया जाएगा। तो
यह ट्रेनिंग उनको फ्री में मिल जाएगी टॉप
थ्री विनर्स को। एंड जो लास्ट हमारे विनर
मतलब कि फोर्थ विनर होंगे उनको ट्राईकमी
प्लेटफार्म का प्रीमियम वाउचर मिलेगा। आप
देखोगे यहां पे प्राइसिंग। मैं प्राइसिंग
दिखा देता हूं आपको इफ इट इज़ विज़िबल। यहां
पे आप देख सकते होंगे कि अगर मैं यहां पे
1 साल की कंपैरिजन करूं यहां पे मैं
एनुअली अगर पर मंथ की भी मैं बात करूं तो
लगभग ₹500 पड़ते हैं। लगभग मैं पर मंथ की
बात कर रहा हूं तो एक साल की वाउचर जो है
इनको फ्री में मिलेगी ट्राईक की यानी कि
आप 500 * 12 कर दीजिए लगभग तो उतने वाउचर
मतलब ऑलमोस्ट ₹6000 के वाउचर जो है वो
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] एक साल का
प्रीमियम ट्राईक का मिल जाएगा उनको फोर्थ
वाले विनर को एंड वो लिटरली किसी के भी
लाइफ चेंज कर सकता है इफ यू हैव वन ईयर
ट्राईक में वाउचर मैंने वन मंथ या सिक्स
मंथ्स का नहीं यहां पे मैं दे रहा हूं
यहां पे वन ईयर का दे रहा हूं तो इट्स अ
बिग थिंग तो इस गिव अवे में पार्टिसिपेट
सभी लोग कर लीजिएगा। राइट? चलिए
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] नाउ नेक्स्ट इज़
यहां पे
Lindin पे ही आप डिफ़्रॉनिक्स सर्च करेंगे
तो हमारी डिफ़्रॉनिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी की
हमारी कंपनी की पेज आपको मिल जाती है।
कंपनी के पेज को फॉलो कर लीजिएगा। लगभग
22,000 लोगों ने फॉलो कर रखा है। कंपनी से
रिगार्डिंग जितने भी लाइक अपडेट्स हैं,
जितने भी नोटिफिकेशंस हैं, कोर्स है,
ट्रेनिंग्स, अपकमिंग हमारे जो भी व्हाटएवर
वी आर गोइंग टू डू एज़ अ स्टार्टअप एज़ अ
थिंग सब आपको यहां पे मिलेगा। जो भी अगर
हायरिंग वगैरह हो रही है कुछ भी हो रही है
तो आपको सबकी नोटिफिकेशन यहां से मिल
जाएगी। तो प्लीज़ कर लीजिएगा। यह हमारी
डिफ़ॉन साइबर सिक्योरिटी की एक्स पेज है।
Twitter पेज है। आप इसको डिफ़ॉन Academy
हैंडल से फॉलो कर सकते हैं यहां पे। यह
मेरी पर्सनल अ Instagram पेज है। आप इसको
फॉलो कर सकते हैं। ये डिफ़्रॉनिक्स की
Instagram पेज है डिफ़ॉन Academy को। एंड
ये हमारी वेबसाइट है जिस पे आके आप हमारी
डिटेल्स वगैरह चेक आउट कर सकते हैं। एकडमी
पे जाके हमारी जो कोर्सर्सेस जो हम ऑफर
करते हैं उनको आप एक्सप्लोर कर सकते हैं।
ये हमारा नंबर है जिसप आप कोई भी क्वेरी
कोई भी क्वेश्चन किसी भी तरह का इंटरेक्शन
करना हो इस पे WhatsApp कर सकते हैं।
दैट्स इट। चलिए तो अब हम स्टार्ट करते हैं
आज की क्लास। आज की क्लास
एक्चुअली जो टॉपिक है आज की वो मैं मानता
हूं कि वन ऑफ द मोस्ट अ
लाइक मोस्ट इंटरेस्टिंग एंड मोस्ट
डिमांडिंग टॉपिक मैं आज आपके लिए लेकर आया
हूं। एंड आई होप कि आप इसको उतना ही
सिंसियरली जो है समझेंगे आज के टॉपिक को।
ठीक है? चलिए मैं यहां पर मोबाइल पर भी
इसको ओपन कर लेता हूं
ताकि मुझे थोड़ा दिखता रहे कि सब चंगा सी।
या आप जा सकते हैं एडब्ल्यूएस के उसके
एडब्ल्यूएस सर्टिफिकेशन के लिए बिल्कुल जा
सकते हैं। कोई इशू नहीं है। यस कोठारी
थैंक यू यश फॉर द सुपर चैट ब्रदर। लेट्स
गो।
लेट्स गो। लेट्स गो।
चलिए
लाइक ठोकते जाना। सभी लोग लाइक ठोक देना
एक बार फटाफट। राइट?
ओके।
आज हम एक्टिव डायरेक्टर के बारे में
जानेंगे।
व्हाट इज एक्टिव डायरेक्टर? एक्सक्टली
क्यों यह इतना इंपॉर्टेंट होता है?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] अबब्सोलुटली
आज जीडी इवनिंग नहीं है। गुड इवनिंग नहीं
है। आज एडी इवनिंग सही है। अच्छा अच्छा
बना लेते हो तुम लोग। चलो। सो एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरी पहली बात क्या होता है? देखो
मैं बहुत ही लेमन लैंग्वेज बहुत ही सिंपल
तरीके से बताऊंगा। जो भी चीजें बताऊंगा
मैं कोई भी बहुत ज्यादा हाई टेक्निकिटी
में जाके नहीं बताऊंगा क्योंकि उस तरीके
से एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी आप समझ नहीं पाओगे
सही से। तो आपको अगर समझना है तो सिंपल सा
फंडा है। मैं आपको बताता हूं। एक एक मैं
इसको छोड़ो अभी। मैं आपको सिंपल सा एक वो
बताता हूं। एक तरीके से एक एग्जांपल के
थ्रू बताता हूं। देखो जैसे आप अपने घर में
या
आप अपने घर में एक लैपटॉप को यूज़ करते हो
या किसी छोटे-मोटे कंपनीज़ में कुछ कुछ आध
जैसे 10 20 एंप्लाइजज़ हैं तो 10 20 लैपटॉप
यूज़ करते हैं। उनको मैनेज करना बड़ा आसान
होता है। सिंपल मतलब जो भी अगर मान लो कोई
सॉफ्टवेयर डालना है 10-20 लैपटॉप में डाल
लिया एक-एक करके सब कुछ बहुत ईजी हो जाता
है। बट कोई ऐसी कंपनी जहां पे
2000 3000 5000 10-100 एंप्लई काम कर रहे
हैं। मल्टीपल ब्रांचेस पे काम कर रहे हैं।
मल्टीपल लोकेशनेशंस पे काम कर रहे हैं।
मल्टीपल उनके यूनिट्स हैं। और सारे
एंप्लाइजज़ के लैपटॉप में, सारे एंप्लाइजज़
के जो मशीन है उनमें एक बार में अगर सारे
सॉफ्टवेयर्स को अपडेट करना हो, एक बार में
अगर सॉफ्टवेयर्स को इंस्टॉल करना हो,
रिमूव करना हो, एक बार में जितने भी यूजर
अकाउंट बने हैं उन लैपटॉप्स पे, उनके अंदर
कोई परमिशन चेंज करने हो कि भाई किसी भी
जितने भी एंप्लई हैं, जो भी यूजर आईडीज
क्रिएटेड हैं, उनमें हम परमिशन ये लगाना
चाहते हैं कि इस पर्टिकुलर पाथ को एक्सेस
ना कर पाए या उनका हम प्रिविलेज
डीएस्केलेट करना चाहते हैं। हम उनको एक
ग्रुप ऑफ पीपल को एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर से
नॉर्मल यूजर बनाना चाहते हैं। इस तरीके की
परमिशंस चेंज करना चाहते हैं। या किसी भी
तरह का कलेक्टिव काम करना चाहते हैं।
थाउजेंड्स ऑफ लैपटॉप, थाउजेंड्स ऑफ यूज़र्स
के ऊपर एक साथ। उसके लिए ही एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरी का जन्म हुआ। एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरी इसीलिए यूज़ किया जाता है।
दैट्स इट। सिंपल सा फंडा है टू मैनेज
कॉम्प्लेक्स
यूजर एनवायरमेंट जहां पे कॉम्प्लेक्स जो
भी यूज़र्स की एनवायरमेंट है बेसिकली
मल्टीपल थाउजेंड्स ऑफ यूज़र्स एक
कॉम्प्लेक्स एनवायरमेंट को मैनेज करने के
लिए एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी जो है उसका यूज़
किया जाता है। बस और कुछ भी नहीं होता।
जैसे सिंगल कंप्यूटर पे आप सारे काम एक-एक
करके करते हो। एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी के थ्रू
आप थाउजेंड्स ऑफ कंप्यूटरटर्स यानी
थाउजेंड्स ऑफ यूज़र्स पे एक साथ एक
पर्टिकुलर ऑपरेशन को एग्जीक्यूट कर सकते
हो। सिंपल एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी पूरी एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरी यही है। पूरी की पूरी एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरी यही है जो मैंने आपको बताया।
अब उसी के अंदर ना चीजों को डिवाइड की गई
है अलग-अलग हिस्सों में। मतलब अब यार एक
साथ खिचपिच हो जाती है। तो छोटे-छोटे
हिस्सों में कि भैया एक पार्ट तुम ये कर
लो, एक पार्ट तुम्हारा रहेगा, एक पार्ट ये
रहेगा, एक पार्ट वो रहेगा ताकि जो है वो
इजी टू मैनेज हो जाए। मतलब एक यूनिट वाइज
डिवाइड कर दिया गया है ताकि वो इजी टू
मैनेज हो जाए। बस दैट्स इट। ठीक है? अब
चलिए। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] थिंक ऑफ़ एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरी ऐज़ द ब्रेन और मैनेजर ऑफ़ अ
कंपनीज़ कंप्यूटर नेटवर्क। बस कंप्यूटर
नेटवर्क कंपनी का कोई कंप्यूटर नेटवर्क
है। उसका ब्रेन या उसका एक मैनेजर समझ
लीजिए। अब यह कौन सी कंपनी है? यह है बड़ी
कंपनीज़। ये कोई छोटी-मोटी कंपनीज़ की बात
नहीं हो रही है। उन कंपनीज़ की बात हो रही
है जिनके पास हजारों की संख्या में
एंप्लाइजज़ होते हैं। हजारों के नंबर्स में
कंप्यूटरटर्स होते हैं। यहां ऐसी कंपनीज़
की बात नहीं हो रही है जहां चारप लैपटॉप,
10 लैपटॉप काम कर रहे हैं। वी आर नॉट
टॉकिंग अबाउट दोज़ लैपटॉप्स। दोज़ कंपनीज़
बिकॉज़ वहां पे एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी का
कांसेप्ट काम ही नहीं करता है और वहां पे
कोई मतलब ही नहीं है। कोई जरूरत ही नहीं
है। अब जैसे कि अब देखो इन अ स्मॉल होम यू
माइट हैव वन लैपटॉप वेयर यू लॉग इन विद
योर ओन पासवर्ड। ठीक है? बट इन अ बिग
कंपनी विद 5000 एंप्लई 5000 लैपटॉप्स यू
कांट मैनुअली क्रिएट एन अकाउंट फॉर एव्री
पर्सन ऑन एव्री सिंगल लैपटॉप। बिल्कुल सही
बात है। नहीं कर सकते ना? हर सिंगल सिंगल
लैपटॉप पे एक अकाउंट हर लैपटॉप पे जा के
अकाउंट क्रिएट करना दिस इज़ नॉट पॉसिबल।
अगर 5000 लैपटॉप है तो राइट यह तो फिजिबल
ही नहीं है। एडी सॉल्स एक्टिव रक्टिव सा्स
दिस बाय क्रिएटिंग अ सेंट्रलाइज़्ड फोन बुक
वेयर एवरीवन आइडेंटिटी इज़ स्टर्ड वंस एंड
दे कैन यूज़ इट टू लॉग इनू एनी कंप्यूटर इन
द कंपनी। तो एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी कुछ इस
तरीके से काम करता है कि ये एक
सेंट्रलाइज्ड एक जगह होती है। एक
सेंट्रलाइज्ड जगह होता है। जहां पे सारे
यूज़र्स की सारे एंप्लाइजज़ की आइडेंटिटी
स्टोर कर दी जाती है। उनका एक्सेस स्टोर
कर दिया जाता है। अब जब वो आइडेंटिटी के
साथ जब इंफॉर्मेशन स्टोर हो जाती है तो वह
एंप्लई जो है कंपनी के पर्टिकुलर
कंप्यूटर्स पे जाएगा। वहां लॉगिन कर सकता
है। अकाउंट अपना मैनेज कर सकता है। सब कुछ
कर सकता है। जो भी उसको प्रिविलेजेस असाइन
हुए हैं उस प्रिविलेज के अकॉर्डिंग दे कैन
डू एनीथिंग। सिंपल एज सिंपल एज दैट। ठीक
है? ये होता है काम आपका एडी का। अब
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़] ये तो
आपको समझ में आ गया होगा। राइट? अब
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] यहां पे आते
हैं। इसका कोर कांसेप्ट क्या है एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरी का? वो है आइडेंटिटी एंड
एक्सेस। बस यही दो चीजें जो होती हैं एडी
के थ्रू होती है। तो एडी दो चीजों को
एग्जीक्यूट करता है। दो चीजों को मैनेज
करता है। एक ऑथेंटिकेशन होती है और एक
ऑथराइजेशन होती है। एज सिंपल एज दैट। कोई
भी आपसे पूछे किसी भी तरह के इंटरव्यू में
कहीं पे भी आप जाओ टेक्निकली या कुछ भी तो
आपको दो चीजें याद रखनी है। ऑथेंटिकेशन
एंड ऑथराइजेशन आइडेंटिटी एंड एक्सेस। बस
इसी को मैनेज करता है। ऑथेंटिकेशन क्या
होती है? वेरीफाइंग यू आर हु यू से यू आर
मतलब ऑथेंटिकेशन का मतलब होता है सिंपल सा
वेरीफाई करना। अब मान लो किसी जा रहे हो
किसी घर का लॉक खोल रहे हो तो जिस ताले को
तुम खोल रहे हो उसकी चाबी से खोलोगे तभी
तो खुलेगा। अगर तुम दूसरी चाबी लगाओगे तो
वो समझ जाएगा कि अरे भाई ये तो हमारी चाबी
नहीं है। ये तो हम खोलेंगे नहीं से।
ऑब्वियस सी बात है। वही ऑथेंटिकेशन काम
होता है कि ये वेरीफाई करता है कि
एक्चुअली आप वही हो ना जो बोल रहे हो। ठीक
है?
यस दिस इज जॉन डस पासवर्ड तो मतलब तुम अगर
तुम वही हो तो हां ठीक है मैं ही हूं तो
यू आर ऑथेंटिकेटेड ऑथोराइजेशन ऑथोराइजेशन
का मतलब चेकिंग इफ यू आर अलाउड टू डू
समथिंग इसका मतलब ये होता है कि आप कोई एक
पर्टिकुलर चीज को एग्जीक्यूट करने के लिए
एक्चुअली अलाउड हो या नहीं हो यह
ऑथराइजेशन चेक करता है। जॉन इज़ अलाउड टू
यूज़ एचआर प्रिंटर बट नॉट द फाइनेंस
फोल्डर। तो जॉन को क्या चीज अलाउड है?
एचआर का प्रिंटर यूज़ करना अलाउड है। बट
फाइनेंस फोल्डर को यूज़ करना अलाउड नहीं
है। वो उसके क्या ऑथ ऑथॉरिटी के बाहर है।
उसके ऑथराइजेशन से बाहर है। सिंपल यही मेन
काम दो चीजें करता है आपका एडी एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरी। बस आपको दिमाग में कांसेप्ट्स
को बैठाना है। जैसे-जैसे कांसेप्ट्स बैठ
जाएंगे आपको टेक्निकल और कॉम्प्लेक्स
चीजें जो हैं वो काफी इजी लगने लगेंगी।
दैट दोज़ विल बिकम क्वाइट इजी फॉर यू ऑल।
सिंपल। ठीक है?
समझ में आया? इतना यहां तक समझ में आया?
यहां तक अभी बहुत बहुत इजी था। मुझे बताइए
एक बार सभी लोग। एवरीवन प्लीज लेट मी नो।
यहां तक समझ में आया आपको? द चैट्स। बताइए
जल्दी फटाफट बताइए
प्लीज एवरीबडी सभी लोग रिप्लाई कीजिए
फटाफट
आर यू गेटिंग
कांसेप्ट मतलब सिंपल एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी का
समझ में आ गया ना कि क्या होता है एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरी का सिंपल कांसेप्ट समझ में आया
कि क्या होता है एक्सैक्टली
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके चलिए गुड। अच्छी बात है। अब हम आगे की
तरफ बढ़ते हैं। एक-एक करके बढ़ेंगे। मजा
आएगा समझने में। ठीक है? आगे की तरफ बढ़ते
हैं। अब हम इस डायग्राम पे आते हैं। अब यह
डायग्राम देखने में कैसा लग रहा है? अजीब
थोड़ा सा खतरनाक लग रहा है ना? डेंजरस लग
रहा है। ठीक है? तो अब हम यहां पे कुछ की
टर्म्स को समझेंगे। की टर्म्स को पढ़ेंगे।
एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी के अंदर में जो की
टर्म्स होते हैं उनको हम समझेंगे। ठीक है?
की टर्म्स में सबसे पहला जो आता है वो है
ऑब्जेक्ट्स।
ऑब्जेक्ट्स। एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी में हम
यहां पे लोअर से अपर साइड की तरफ बढ़ रहे
हैं। ऑब्जेक्ट्स। सबसे कोर वाले से बढ़
रहा है। ऑब्जेक्ट्स का मतलब होता है जो भी
यूज़र्स हो गए हैं, कंप्यूटर हो गया,
प्रिंटर हो गया, ग्रुप्स हो गया वो सारे
ऑब्जेक्ट्स कहलाते हैं। ठीक है? जो यूज़र्स
हो गए, जो भी डिवाइसेस हैं, जो भी
रिसोर्सेज हैं, प्रिंटर्स हैं, कंप्यूटर
सब ऑब्जेक्ट होते हैं। एक एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरी के अंदर में। उसके बाद आते हैं
ऑर्गेनाइजेशनल यूनिट्स।
इनको हम लॉजिकल कंटेनर्स बोलते हैं। ओयूस
ऑर्गेनाइजेशनल यूनिट। क्या
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] होते हैं
यहां पे? फोल्डर्स टू ग्रुप ऑब्जेक्ट्स
फॉर इजी मैनेजमेंट। अब ये इसको आप समझ
लीजिए कि एक फोल्डर है। इसको आप एक फोल्डर
समझ लीजिए। तो जो हमने यहां ऑब्जेक्ट्स को
देखा ना जैसे यूज़र्स हैं, कंप्यूटरटर्स
हैं। तो एक यू एक टाइप के यूज़र्स को एक
फोल्डर में डाल दिया। एक ग्रुप्स एक टाइप
के ग्रुप्स को एक फोल्डर में डाल दिया। एक
टाइप के कंप्यूटर्स को एक फोल्डर में डाल
दिया ताकि उस फोल्डर की परमिशन जब चेंज
करें या फोल्डर के ऊपर कोई चीज हम कोई
सेटिंग्स अप्लाई करें तो पूरे यूज़र्स पे
अप्लाई हो जाए। ग्रुप्स पे अप्लाई हो जाए,
कंप्यूटरटर्स पे अप्लाई हो जाए, डिवाइसेस
पे अप्लाई हो जाए। तो एक फोल्डर हो गया।
ये ऑर्गेनाइजेशनल यूनिट्स इसको हम बोलते
हैं। तीसरा आ गया आपका डोमेन। ये एक
सिक्योरिटी बाउंड्री इसको कहा जाता है।
डोमेन का मतलब सिंपल सा क्या है? सिंपल
सा। अ सेंट्रल डिफाइंड एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव
कंटेन इट्स ओन डेटाबेस एंड पॉलिसीज़। अब ये
डोमेनस जो होते हैं बेसिकली जैसे कि आप
नॉर्मल डोमेन जानते हो ना dfonic.com तो
ये dfonic.com क्या रिप्रेजेंट करते हैं?
ये एक सर्वर को ही तो रिप्रेजेंट करते
हैं। एक सर्वर को डोमेन नेम के थ्रू
रिप्रेजेंट करते हैं। सिंपल उसी तरीके से
यहां डोमेनस यहां भी जो डोमेन है ये एक
सर्वर को जिसको कि हम अ डीसी बोलते हैं।
यहां पे हम उसके ऊपर भी आएंगे। कि डोमेन
कंट्रोलर सर्वर जो होते हैं तो उसको
रिप्रेजेंट करते हैं। बेसिकली डीसी यानी
कि डीसी डोमेन कंट्रोलर डोमेन कंट्रोलर
होता है डीसी ये एक सर्वर होता है।
बेसिकली उसको ये रिप्रेजेंट करते हैं एक
नाम से जैसे abcdfish.com
कुछ भी नाम हो सकता है उसका। लोकल नेम
होता है। कुछ भी नाम आपका इसको हो सकता
है। जब तक आप लोकल यूज़ कर रहे हैं। देख यू
कैन यूज़ एनी नेम। तो ये डोमेन होते हैं
सर्वर्स को रिप्रेजेंट करने के लिए। उसके
बाद आते हैं फॉरेस्ट एंड ट्रीज़।
अब देखो यह फॉरेस्ट एंट्रीज के ऊपर मैं और
डिटेल में भी बताऊंगा आने वाले आने आने
वाले टाइम में क्या बोल रहा है बेस्ट
ऑप्शन डिफ्रॉनिक्स यूनिवर्सिटी ओपन फॉर ऑल
[हंसी]
डिफ्रॉनिक्स यूनिवर्सिटी चलो अच्छी बात है
अच्छा अच्छी सोच है वैसे तो यूनिवर्सिटी
ओपन करना इतना आसान नहीं है एंड इट इट
टेक्स अ लॉट ऑफ़ लॉट ऑफ़ मनी टू ओपन अ
यूनिवर्सिटी [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके फॉरेस्ट कभी फ्यूचर में देखेंगे कभी
फ्यूचर में ऐसा कुछ हुआ तो बिल्कुल ऐसे एक
ऐसी यूनिवर्सिटी ओपन भी कर सकते हैं जहां
पे सबसे अफोर्डेबल फी में पढ़ाई हो और
साइबर सिक्योरिटी की एक अलग लेवल पर पढ़ाई
हो और कोई भी एक पुअर फैमिली का भी बंदा
वहां पे आके उतने ही उसी लेवल की पढ़ाई
करें जो एक रिच परिवार से बंदा आ रहा है।
सब सेम हो और सब लगभग सेम क्वालिटी ऑफ़
एजुकेशन हो। ऐसा नहीं कि डिवाइड कर दिया
जाए। मेडिकल और इसमें होता है ना बैचेस
में जाओगे तुम्हें ए बी सी बैच में डालते
ए वाले टॉपर बैच बी वाले उससे नीचे सी
वाले उससे नीचे डी ई को टीचर ही नहीं
मिलते अच्छे तो वहां भी एक डिफरेंशिएट
किया जाता है हर जगह डिफरेंशिएट किया जाता
है दिस इज़ नॉट डन एजुकेशन देयर शुड बी नो
डिफरेंशिएशन इन एजुकेशन स्पेशली एजुकेशन
सबके लिए बराबर होना चाहिए एंड हर बंदे को
इक्वली इक्वल तरीके से इक्वल अ वे में
मिलना चाहिए मुझे ऐसा लगता है मुझे ऐसा
मेरा ऐसा मानना है बाकी तो ठीक फॉरेस्ट
एंड ट्रीज के ऊपर आते हैं। ठीक है?
फॉरेस्ट एंड ट्रीज की जब हम बात करते हैं,
तो देखो, अब मैं यहां पे बताता हूं
फॉरेस्ट क्या होता है? फॉरेस्ट सारे ट्रीज
का एक कॉम्बिनेशन हो गया। ठीक है? फॉरेस्ट
का मतलब तुम्हें भी पता है। बट एडी में
फॉरेस्ट और ट्री ये टर्म बहुत ज्यादा
इंपॉर्टेंट टर्म है। याद रखिएगा। ये टर्म
एक्चुअल टर्म है एडीज के अंदर में। तो
फॉरेस्ट का मतलब एक कलेक्शन ऑफ़ ट्रीज़।
सिंपल। अब ट्रीज़ क्या है? देखो यहां पे द
हाईएस्ट कंटेनर द हाईएस्ट कंटेनर अ
कलेक्शन ऑफ डोमेनस दैट ट्रस्ट ईच अदर
ट्रीज़ में डोमेनस का कलेक्शन होता है।
जैसे पहले तो ऑब्जेक्ट जो सबसे लोअर लेवल
के होते हैं यूजर कंप्यूटर प्रिंटर उन
सबको फोल्डर फोल्डर में डिवाइड करके रख
दिया ऑर्गेनाइजेशन यूनिट्स उन सबको
रिप्रेजेंट कर रहा है एक डोमेन जो कि
सर्वर को रिप्रेजेंट करता है और वहीं जब
मल्टीपल डोमेनस को एक साथ कलेक्ट करके रख
देते हैं तो डोमेन ट्रीज़ हो जाते हैं। वो
एक साथ कलेक्ट करके वो हो जाते हैं ट्रीज़।
और वहीं सारे ट्रीज मिलके एक फॉरेस्ट
बनाते हैं। एक फॉरेस्ट हो जाता है। मतलब
मल्टीपल कलेक्शन ऑफ डोमेनस कॉल्ड ट्रीज़।
मल्टीपल कलेक्शन ऑफ ट्रीज़ फॉर्म्स अ
फॉरेस्ट। ये तो नॉर्मल सा कांसेप्ट है कि
हां ट्रीज़ बहुत सारे हैं तो फॉरेस्ट है।
एज सिंपल एज दैट। अब यहां पे की फंक्शन
आपको बता दिया है मैंने कि ऑथेंटिकेशन
ऑथराइजेशन का होता है। और एडी में दो
फिजिकल चीजें भी होती है। एक होता है
डोमेन कंट्रोलर और एक होता है साइट्स। दो
चीजें होती है। ये तो आपको डिजिटल चीजें
मैंने आपको बताई। ऑब्जेक्ट्स ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
यूनिट फॉरे हिस्ट्री ये सारे तो डिजिटल
चीजें हो गई कि हां लेकिन फिजिकल चीजें दो
होती हैं एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी में एक आपका
डोमेन कंट्रोलर होता है यानी कि जो
एक्चुअल सर्वर जो होता है ना उसकी बात मैं
कर रहा हूं डीसी जिसको हम डीसी बोलते हैं
ये तुम यहां डीसी तुम वो डीसी कॉमिक्स
वाले में मत चले जाना और ये है साइट्स
यानी फिजिकल लोकेशनेशंस जो सर्वर के
फिजिकल लोकेशनेशंस होते हैं जहां पे डीसीस
का सेटअप किया जाता है जहां पे डीसी
प्रेजेंट है वो साइट्स होते हैं। ठीक है?
यह पूरा का पूरा एक एक टर्मिनोलॉजी या यू
कैन से कि कुछ कॉमोनेंट्स के नाम थे जो
मैंने आपको बताएं। इन सारे कॉमोनेंट्स के
नाम दिमाग में फिट कर लीजिए अभी क्लास के
लिए। आने वाले अभी स्लाइड्स में आपको काम
आएंगे। सिंपल सा फंडा है। आप सभी से मैं
एक रिक्वेस्ट करता हूं कि आप सब ने यहां
पे कौन-कौन से कंपोनेंट के नाम अभी पढ़े
हैं। यह मुझे चैट में बताइए ताकि आपका एक
फ्रीक्वेंट एक तुरंत क्विक रिवीज़ हो जाए।
एंड आगे के लिए आपको कल क्योंकि अगर आप
भूल जाएंगे तो आगे के स्लाइड्स में थोड़ी
आपको दिक्कत आएगी। तो जल्दी-जल्दी क्विक
आप सभी लोग से मैं रिक्वेस्ट करता हूं। 40
से ऊपर लोग हैं लगभग यहां पे कि प्लीज
टाइप इन द चैट कि यहां पे आपने कौन-कौन से
कॉम्पोनेंट्स के बारे में पढ़ा है? सारे
कॉम्पोनेंट्स का नाम बताइए। ठीक है? जल्दी
बताइए फटाफट। एवरीवन एक साथ लिखिए सारे
कॉम्पोनेंट्स एंड देन चैट में मैसेज
भेजिए। एक साथ लिखिए तब मैसेज भेजिए।
अलग-अलग मत लिख के भेजो। एक साथ लिख दो
सारे और फिर मैसेज भेजो चैट में।
जल्दी बताइए फटाफट।
फ़ास्ट फ़ास्ट
थैंक यू।
पेन
फॉर द पीपीटी ओके
ओके ऑब्जेक्ट्स ऑ्गेनाइजेशन यूनिट्स
डोमेनस फॉरेस्ट ट्रेस बिल्कुल सही
ऑब्जेक्ट्स ऑ्गेनाइजेशन यूनिट डोमेन
फॉरेस्ट एंड ट्रेस बिल्कुल ऑब्जेक्ट्स
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन यूनिट डोमेनस फॉरेस्ट
ट्रेज एंड एक डोमेन कंट्रोलर भी हमने करा
है डीसी जिसको हम बोलते हैं जो कि एक
एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी का सर्वर होता है जो
सर्वर एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी को एक्चुअली चला
रही है। डोमेन कंट्रोलर कुछ भी नहीं होता
है। जो हमने यहां डोमेन की बात की। डोमेन
कंट्रोलर जो होता है वह वही सर्वर होता है
जो एक्चुअली एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी को रन कर
रही है। बस चलिए
अब आगे की तरफ। अब आप लोग एकदम रेडी हैं
फॉर द नेक्स्ट स्लाइड। अब यहां पे आते हैं
एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी के इकोसिस्टम के बारे
में थोड़ा सा समझते
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] हैं। ठीक है?
इकोसिस्टम को समझते हैं। थोड़ा यहां पे
समझिएगा। यहां पे दो जोों्स में है यहां
पे जोन वन ठीक है एंड यहां पे जोन टू दो
जीन एक जोन वन जो है वो स्ट्रक्चर है जोन
टू है क्या मैनेज किया जाता है उसके बारे
में हम देखेंगे ठीक है दो चीजें
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
थैंक यू अ
आई एम ज्ञानेश थैंक यू ज्ञानश फॉर दिस
वंडरफुल कमेंट फॉर ट्रस्टिंग अस ऑलवेज
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
सो यहां पे दो जोों्स हैं। अब अभी जो मैं
चीजें बता रहा हूं ना इसको मैं एक्सप्लेन
भी करूंगा। इसको मैं टेक्सचुअल एक्सप्लेन
भी करूंगा। आपको डिटेल एक्सप्लेनेशन के
साथ टेक्निकल एक्सप्लेनेशन के साथ भी आगे
वाले स्लाइड्स में बताऊंगा। तो आपको और भी
क्लियर होगा। अभी सिर्फ इमेज के थ्रू मैं
नहीं बताऊंगा और आगे चीजें बताऊंगा मैं
आपको। तो बिल्कुल बेफिक्र रहिए। सब समझ
में आएगा आपको। अभी आपको ये नहीं समझ
आएंगे। अरे यार समझ नहीं आएगा। सब समझ में
आएगा। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
तो यहां पे जोन वन जो है उस पे आते हैं।
तो हम नीचे के नीचे से ऊपर की तरफ आते
हैं। कुछ इस तरीके से काम करता है। सबसे
पहले यूज़र्स एंड ग्रुप्स होते हैं। जैसा
मैंने आपको पहले भी बताया था लास्ट स्लाइड
में ऑब्जेक्ट्स जिसको हम कह देते हैं। ये
ऑब्जेक्ट्स हैं हमारे यूज़र्स एंड ग्रुप्स।
ठीक है? तो यहां आप देख सकते हैं यूज़र्स
हैं। इनको ग्रुप्स में डिवाइड किया गया।
फिर इन सबको एक फोल्डर में ऑर्गेनाइजेशनल
यूनिट के अंदर डाला गया। एंड उस पे ग्रुप
पॉलिसीज को सेट किया गया। ऑर्गेनाइजेशनल
यूनिट में डाला गया। एक ग्रुप बना दिया
गया। उसके ऊपर होते हैं ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
यूनिट्स। बस वही चीजें हैं लॉजिकल
फोल्डर्स। ठीक है? इसमें यही फोल्डर्स
अलग-अलग नाम से फोल्डर्स हैं। अब जैसे यार
सिंपल सा बात है। आपके कंपनी में मान लो
कि एक फाइनेंस डिपार्टमेंट है, एक टेक
डिपार्टमेंट है, एक सिक्योरिटी
डिपार्टमेंट है। तो, आपने क्या किया?
फाइनेंस डिपार्टमेंट के अलग यूज़र्स बना
दिए। उसका नाम एक फाइनेंस डिपार्टमेंट रख
दिया। ठीक है? उसको एक फाइनेंस
डिपार्टमेंट के ग्रुप में डाल दिया।
टेक्निकल डिपार्टमेंट को एक टेक्निकल सारे
यूज़र्स को एक साथ डाल के टेक्निकल
डिपार्टमेंट का एक ग्रुप बना दिया। उसको
उसमें डाल दिया। सिक्योरिटी वाले को एक
ग्रुप में डाल दिया। तो ग्रुप्स ही तो बना
रहे हो आप। ग्रुप्स बस और उसी ग्रुप्स पे
एक-एक ग्रुप पे एक पॉलिसी असाइन आप कर
सकते हो। आप सिक्योरिटी पॉलिसीज लगा सकते
हो। आप अलग-अलग तरह की पॉलिसीज बना सकते
हो। अब मान लो आपको मान लो फाइनेंस
डिपार्टमेंट के लिए एक पॉलिसी बनानी है।
पॉलिसी क्या बनानी कि फाइनेंस डिपार्टमेंट
के लोगों के पास एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव एक्सेस
नहीं हो सकता है। एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव एक्सेस
उनके पास नहीं होगा। दूसरी क्या होगी कि
वो किसी भी एग्जीक्यूटेबल फाइल को सिस्टम
पे एग्जीक्यूट नहीं कर सकते हैं। दूसरा
पॉलिसी ये बना लो। तीसरी पॉलिसी हो सकती
है कि किसी भी ईमेल अटैचमेंट को वो
डाउनलोड नहीं कर सकते हैं। मान लो लेट्स
सपोज ये तीन रूल बना दिए फाइनेंस
डिपार्टमेंट के लिए। अब इन तीन रूलों को
एक साथ फाइनेंस डिपार्टमेंट के ये फोल्डर
जो बने हैं ना ऑर्गेनाइजेशन यूनिट वाला
फोल्डर इसके ऊपर ग्रुप पॉलिसी के थ्रू ये
पॉलिसी को अप्लाई कर दिया। तो अब उसके
अंदर जितने भी यूज़र्स हैं फाइनेंस उस सब
पे वो पॉलिसी अप्लाई हो जाएगी। एज सिंपल
एज दैट। तो बहुत ईजी टू मैनेज हो गया।
राइट? इट्स क्वाइट ईजी टू मैनेज ना। अगर
ऐसे हम देखें तो ये तो काफी ईजी हो गया
मैनेज करना। अगर हम अलग-अलग करते तो ये
बहुत लें्थी प्रोसेस हो जाता।
राइट? सो दिस बिकम्स वेरी वेरी वेरी इजी
थिंग। अब
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन यूनिट हो गए हमारे ये। इसी
के ऊपर हमारे आते हैं ट्री
एंड डोमेनस। जैसा मैंने पहले भी बताया
डोमेन क्या हो गया? सिक्योरिटी बाउंड्री
है। ये एक सेंट्रल डेटाबेस ऑफ ऑब्जेक्ट्स
एंड पॉलिसीज है जो कि सेल्फ कंटेंट
एडमिनिस्ट्रेशन होता है। तो जो भी आपने
पॉलिसीज बनाई हैं। ठीक है? जो भी
ऑब्जेक्ट्स की हम बात कर रहे हैं उनका एक
सेंट्रल डेटाबेस है डोमेन। वो डोमेन ही
है। सारे जब एक साथ मिला दोगे वो सब एक
डोमेन कहलाते हैं। ठीक है? ट्री अ कॉमन
नेम स्पेस सिंगल नेम स्पेस ऑफ द कनेक्टेड
डोमेन ये ट्री होते हैं। जैसे कि अब
ukcc.net
us.cop.net तो ये ट्री के फॉर्म में ये
ट्री कहलाते हैं। मतलब एक कॉमन नेम स्पेस
जो हमने डोमेन में दिया है वो ट्री कहलाते
हैं। तो ट्रीज़ क्या है? कलेक्शन ऑफ डोमेनस
हो गया। ठीक है? मतलब कि जितने भी डोमेनस
की हम यहां पर बात कर रहे हैं, द नंबर ऑफ
डोमेनस वी आर टॉकिंग हियर जैसे कि ये सारे
डोमेनस ये डोमेन मल्टीपल डोमेनस हैं। उन
सबको कंबाइन कर दो तो यहां पे क्या हो
गया? वो ट्री कहलाता है। ठीक है? फॉरेस्ट
क्या होता है? कंप्लीट इकोसिस्टम हाईएस्ट
सिक्योरिटी बाउंड्री कनेक्ट्स अनरिलेटेड
ट्रीज़ थ्रू ट्रांजिटिव ट्रस्ट। मतलब
फॉरेस्ट सारे ट्रीज़ को मिला दिए। तो एक
फॉरेस्ट हो गया। उसी तरीके से मल्टीपल
फॉरेस्ट्स होंगे। एक फॉरेस्ट होगा एक्टिव
राइटरी के अंदर में दूसरा फॉरेस्ट होगा।
तीसरा फॉरेस्ट होगा। अब एक फॉरेस्ट को
दूसरे फॉरेस्ट से कनेक्ट कर सकते हैं।
दूसरे फॉरेस्ट को तीसरे फॉरेस्ट से कनेक्ट
कर सकते हैं। और इस तरीके से जो पॉलिसीज
हैं उसको अप्लाई किया जाता है उन फॉरेस्ट
के ऊपर। यानी एक फॉरेस्ट के ऊपर अगर
अप्लाई कर दिया तो वो पॉलिसी मल्टीपल
डोमेनस पे अप्लाई हो सकते हैं। और इस
तरीके से मल्टीपल डोमेनस हो सकते हैं
मल्टीपल ऑर्गेनाइजेशनल यूनिट्स के। और जब
मल्टीपल ऑर्गेनाइजेशनल यूनिट्स के मल्टीपल
डोमेनस होंगे तो हम मल्टीपल डोमेनस पे
पॉलिसी अप्लाई करेंगे। तो मल्टीपल ट्रीज़
पे हम पॉलिसी अप्लाई करेंगे। मल्टीपल
फॉरेस्ट्स पे हम पॉलिसी अप्लाई करेंगे। तो
मल्टीपल फॉरेस्ट्स हैं, मल्टीपल ट्रीज
हैं, मल्टीपल डोमेनस हैं, मल्टीपल
ऑर्गेनाइजेशनल यूनिट्स हैं। उन सबको एक
डोमेन से बांधा गया, एक ट्री से बांधा
गया, एक फॉरेस्ट बना दिया गया। तो हाईएस्ट
लेवल ऑफ यहां पे सिक्योरिटी बाउंड्री द
सबसे हाईएस्ट ऊपर में वो फॉरेस्ट है जो
जिसके अंदर में मल्टीपल जो है ट्रीज़,
डोमेनस, ऑर्गेनाइजेशन यूनिट्स ये सब आते
हैं। एक पॉलिसी अप्लाई किया उन सब पे
अप्लाई हो रहा है। इस तरीके से ये पूरा का
पूरा एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी काम करता है।
दैट्स इट। सिंपल
एज सिंपल एज यह फोल्डर्स
यह आपको समझ में इतना समझ में तो आया
होगा। ये हायरार्की आपको समझ में आई पहले
यह बताइए फिर हम आगे बढ़ेंगे क्योंकि बिना
इसके हम आगे नहीं बढ़ सकते हैं। आज के
क्लास में थोड़ा सा आपसे पूछ-पूछ के चलना
पड़ेगा। तो मुझे बताइए यहां यह समझ में
आया कि नहीं आया? पहले बताइए। फटाफट
बताइए।
एवरीवन
सभी लोग रिप्लाई कीजिए प्लीज। एवरीबडी
प्लीज रिप्लाई।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
समझ में आ गया? थोड़ा लेट हो गया। कोई बात
नहीं रोहित आ गए तुम। अच्छी बात है। लेट
थोड़ा हो गया। चलेगा बट आ तो गए।
ठीक है। चलिए
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
अभी और समझेंगे। सुजॉय। अभी तो हम आगे अभी
जानेंगे। अभी टेंशन नहीं लेना है। ठीक है?
उसी तरीके से अब यहां पे ऑब्जेक्ट ज़ोन टू
में आते हैं। ऑब्जेक्ट एंड पॉलिसीज के ऊपर
में। तो अब ऑब्जेक्ट पॉलिसी के ऊपर में
आते हैं। तो देखो ऑब्जेक्ट लेयर्स में
क्या होते हैं? यूज़र्स होते हैं।
कंप्यूटरटर्स, प्रिंटर्स, ग्रुप्स होते
हैं। ये सारे होते हैं। अब यूजर क्या होते
हैं? पर्संस लॉग इन क्रेडेंशियल्स एंड
प्रोफाइल। ये तो आपको पता ही है।
कंप्यूटरटर्स, मशीन अकाउंट्स फॉर नेटवर्क
एक्सेस मशीन का अकाउंट होता है। शेयरर्ड
प्रिंटर्स डिवाइसेस जो होते हैं वो हो गए
आपके। एंड ग्रुप्स क्या हो गए? कलेक्शन ऑफ़
यूज़र्स और कंप्यूटरटर्स फॉर सिंपलीफाइड
परमिशनिंग। मतलब ग्रुप्स क्या होते हैं?
कलेक्शन ऑफ़ कंप्यूटरटर्स एंड यूज़र्स होते
हैं। यह ग्रुप्स होते हैं कंप्यूटर बहुत
सारे कंप्यूटर और यूजर का। जैसे बहुत सारे
यूज़र्स को एक ग्रुप में डाल दिया। उस
ग्रुप के ऊपर परमिशन लगा दी तो सारे यूजर
पे अप्लाई हो जाता है। सिंपल ये ग्रुप्स
होते हैं। ये तो आप नॉर्मल जानते होंगे।
अब ग्रुप पॉलिसी द मैनेजमेंट बुक। अब
ग्रुप पॉलिसी में क्या होता है? सेट रूल्स
फॉर ऑल ऑब्जेक्ट्स एट ऑर्गेनाइजेशन यूनिट,
डोमेन और साइट लेवल। सिंपल ग्रुप पॉलिसी
का मतलब यहां पे सिंपल सा फंडा है कि
रूल्स को परमिशंस को सेट करना। जितने भी
ऑब्जेक्ट्स हैं यानी जितने भी यूज़र्स हैं,
कंप्यूटरटर्स हैं, प्रिंटर्स हैं, ग्रुप्स
हैं, ग्रुप्स के ऊपर भी परमिशंस को सेट
करना। यह ग्रुप पॉलिसी के अंदर से इसलिए
ग्रुप पॉलिसी का यूज़ किया जाता है।
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन यूनिट के अंदर में यह सारे
होते हैं। ये सारे आपके ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
यूनिट के अंदर में फॉर्म करते हैं। जितने
भी यूज़र्स हैं, कंप्यूटरटर्स हैं, ग्रुप्स
हैं, सब आपके ऑर्गेनाइजेशन यूनिट में एक
फॉल करते हैं। और उसी ऑर्गेनाइजेशनल यूनिट
के ऊपर ग्रुप पॉलिसीज को लगाया जाता है।
आई थिंक उनके क्वेश्चन का आंसर मिल गया
होगा जो अभी क्वेश्चन कर रहे थे कि ग्रुप
और ओयू में क्या डिफरेंस है? जी ये सब
में। में आई थिंक आपको आपका आंसर मिल गया
होगा कि व्हाट द डिफरेंस एंड एक्चुअली कि
आपका ऑर्गेनाइजेशन यूनिट जो है उसी के
अंदर सब कुछ आता है और उसके ऊपर ग्रुप
पॉलिसीज को अप्लाई किया जाता है एक्टिव
डायरेक्टर के अंदर तो वो सब पे अप्लाई हो
जाता है। गॉट इट
सिविल इंजीनियर टू स्विच एसओसी क्या बात
है
सर आपकी बग बाउंट सीरीज बहुत अच्छी है।
थैंक यू ब्रदर। आई होप यू आर लर्निंग वेल।
ओके ये सारी चीजें होती है। अब
कंप्यूटरटर्स हाउ कॉमोनेंट्स वर्क टुगेदर
सारे कॉमोनेंट्स
एक साथ काम कैसे करते हैं? ये भी तो जानना
जरूरी है। एक साथ कैसे काम करते हैं? तो
देखो एडमिनस ऑर्गेनाइजेशनल यूनिट्स को
क्रिएट करते हैं। ठीक है? फिर ऑब्जेक्ट्स
पुट इंटू ओयूस। ऑब्जेक्ट्स को
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन यूनिट में डाला जाता है।
यानी कि जो भी ऑब्जेक्ट्स होते हैं यूजर,
कंप्यूटर, ग्रुप्स, प्रिंटर उन सबको
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन यूनिट में डाला जाता है।
ग्रुप पॉलिसीज़ अप्लाई टू ओयूस। ग्रुप
पॉलिसी ऑर्गेनाइजेशनल यूनिट के ऊपर अप्लाई
किया जाता है। एंड डोमेन कंट्रोलर्स
इनफोर्स पॉलिसी उसके बाद डोमेन कंट्रोलर
जो है उन पॉलिसीज को इनफोर्स करते हैं।
एंड उन पॉलिसीज के ऊपर ही सारी काम आपकी
होती है। दैट्स इट। यही पूरा का पूरा फ्लो
है। यही है आपकी एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी।
एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी को लेकर बहुत लोग बहुत
ज्यादा
टेंशन में रहते हैं। बहुत ज्यादा चिंतित
रहते हैं। लाइक कि अरे भाई क्या है ये
एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी? व्हाट इज दिस? इतनी
कॉम्प्लेक्स? बहुत लोग इसको बहुत
कॉम्प्लेक्स टॉपिक मानते हैं। लेकिन अगर
आप एक बार समझ लेंगे ना तो इट विल बी द
मोस्ट इज़िएस्ट टॉपिक। क्योंकि यहां पे
सिंपल सा फंडा है कि एक दो तीन
कंप्यूटरटर्स को जो मैनेज आप करते हैं
यहां पे आप समझ लीजिए कि 5000 कंप्यूटर को
मैनेज करना है। जिसमें कि सारे काम आपको
एक फंक्शनैलिटी के वाइज़ या एक लेवल ऑफ़
प्रिविलेज के वाइज़ मैनेज करके अलग-अलग
लोगों पे अलग-अलग तरह की पॉलिसीज़ लगानी
है, सेट करनी है, रूल्स बनाने हैं। उनको
एक साथ अप्लाई करना है हजारों
कंप्यूटरटर्स पे। दैट्स इट। दैट्स व्हाई
एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी इज़ देयर। एंड इसीलिए
इसका बहुत ज्यादा रोल है क्योंकि जब आप
बड़े कंपनीज़ में जाते हो तो आप साइबर
सिक्योरिटी एक्सपर्ट भी हो तो आप एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरी पे ही काम करते हो। आप एक दो
कंप्यूटर पे तो काम नहीं करते। आप
थाउजेंड्स ऑफ़ कंप्यूटरटर्स एंड मशीनंस की
सिक्योरिटी को देखते हो। दैट्स व्हाई
एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी इज़ आस्क्ड इन मेजर सर्च
साइबर सिक्योरिटी सर्टिफिकेशंस। ठीक है?
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
कुछ डिफिकल्ट नहीं है। करबोस भी आसान है।
आपको सब समझ में आ जाएगा। चलिए ये तो आपको
समझ में आया। अब आ जाते हैं यहां पे
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] थोड़ी सी थोड़ी
सी एक्सप्लेनेशन के साइड जहां पे आपको और
इजी वे में मैं बताऊंगा एक्सप्लेनेशन के
थ्रू। एंड यहां से आपकी एक्सप्लेनेशन के
साथ यह और भी ज्यादा इजी लगने लगेगा। जो
आपने पिक्चराइज विजुअलाइज किया है उसी को
अब टेक्सचुअल फॉर्म में जब समझेंगे एक
टेक्निकल डेफिनेशन के थ्रू तो आपको और भी
ज्यादा दिमाग में फिट बैठने लगेगा।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
हां हां हां ऋतू बिल्कुल
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ओके अब यहां पे लॉजिकल स्ट्रक्चर हाउ इट
इज़ ऑर्गेनाइज्ड इसको देखते हैं पहले
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
चलिए टू कीप थिंग्स नीड एडी यूसेस अ
हायरार्की दैट लुक्स लाइक एन अप साइड डाउन
ट्री एक हायरार्की को यूज़ करता है। जैसे
डीएनएस का हायरार्की होता है वैसे ही इसका
एक हायरार्की होता है। सबसे पहले यहां पे
ऑब्जेक्ट्स आते हैं जो कि सबसे स्मालेस्ट
यूनिट होता है। सबसे पहले
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
देयर इज़ देयर आर ऑब्जेक्ट्स स्मालेस्ट
यूनिट इन एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी। द स्मालेस्ट
यूनिट एन ऑब्जेक्ट इज़ अ थिंग इन द
नेटवर्क। नेटवर्क में जो भी थिंग है ना जो
आपको दिख रहा है वो ऑब्जेक्ट है। बस इससे
ज्यादा इजी डेफिनेशन क्या हो सकता है? जो
भी नेटवर्क में आपको दिख रहा है ऑब्जेक्ट
है। जैसे यूजर्स पीपल हु लॉग इन
कंप्यूटरटर्स द एक्चुअल मशीनंस प्रिंटर्स
या शेयरर्ड फोल्डर रिसोर्सेज पीपल नीड टू
यूज़। ये सारे ऑब्जेक्ट्स हैं। उसके बाद
ऑर्गेनाइजेशनल यूनिट्स। थिंक ऑफ दीज़ एज
फोल्डर्स। इसको आप फोल्डर समझिए।
यू पुट योर ऑब्जेक्ट्स इनसाइड
ऑर्गेनाइजेशनल यूनिट्स टू स्टे
ऑर्गेनाइज्ड। तो इसको एक फोल्डर समझिए। एज
सिंपल एज दैट मतलब कि अगर जैसे मान लो
लेट्स सपोज कि यह मेरे पास
मेरे पास ये स्टैंड है। मान लो ये स्टैंड
है। राइट? ये स्टैंड है। अब मैं इस स्टैंड
को यूज़ कर रहा हूं। ये एक ऑब्जेक्ट है। और
इसमें मैंने इस फोन को ऐसे ये फोन को ऐसे
रख दिया। मान लो इस फोन को मैंने इस
स्टैंड पे इस तरीके से रख दिया। तो यह
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
यहां पे यूनिट है जिसके अंदर मैंने यह फोन
रखा। क्यों? ताकि मेरा फोन जो है वह
ऑर्गेनाइज तरीके से इस पे टिका रहे।
ऑर्गेनाइज़ तरीके से इस पे रहे, स्टैंड पे
रहे। तो उसी तरीके से ऑर्गेनाइजेशन यूनिट
जो है वो क्या है? सिंपल सा वो जगह है
जहां पे आप अपने ऑब्जेक्ट्स को रखते हो
ताकि ऑब्जेक्ट्स ऑर्गेनाइज्ड वे में रहे।
दैट्स इट।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़] फॉर
एग्जांपल, यू माइट हैव एन ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
यूनिट फॉर अकाउंटिंग एंड अनदर फॉर सेल्स।
तो आपके पास अलग-अलग डिपार्टमेंट के
ऑर्गेनाइजेशन यूनिट्स हो सकते हैं। एक
अकाउंटिंग का हो सकता है, एक सेल्स का हो
सकता है, एक फाइनेंस का हो सकता है, एक
सिक्योरिटी का हो सकता है। राइट? ये सब
अलग-अलग हो सकता है। यहां तक क्लियर होगा।
अब आते हैं डोमेनस पे। दिस इज़ अ मेन
कंटेनर। दिस इज़ द मेन कंटेनर। इट इज़ अ
बाउंड्री फॉर सिक्योरिटी। सिक्योरिटी
बाउंड्री है ये क्योंकि मेन कंटेनर है।
यूजुअली अ डोमेन लुक्स लाइक अ वेबसाइट
एड्रेस। यह तो मैंने आपको पहले ही बताया
कि डोमेन एक वेबसाइट एड्रेस की तरह लगता
है। जैसे आप google.com या facebook.com
करते हो, dfonic.com करते हो या
academy.com
है, सब डोमेन हो गया। उसी तरीके से या यूं
कहिए एक सब डोमेन टाइप दिखता है। जैसे
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] co. Apple.com
एवरीथिंग इनसाइड दिस डोमेन फॉलोस द सेम
रूल्स। इस डोमेन के अंदर जितनी भी चीजें
हैं, वह सब एक ही रूल को फॉलो करेंगी। सब
एक रूल सारे डोमेन पर अप्लाई होगा। सिंपल।
अब आते हैं ट्रीज एंड फॉरेस्ट पे। तो
ट्रीज क्या है? मैंने पहले ही बताया अ
ग्रुप ऑफ डोमेनस दैट शेयर द सेम नेम मतलब
सेम नेम स्पेस को शेयर करते हो वो हमारे
होते हैं ट्री। जैसे कि sales.com
uk.com आर इन द सेम apple.com ट्री। मतलब
इसको आप डोमेन और सब डोमेन के एंगल से
समझने की कोशिश कीजिए। सबके लिए बहुत इजी
हो जाएगा। जैसे एक डोमेन होता है जैसे
डोमेन है डिफ्रॉनिक्स.com और इसी का एक सब
डोमेन है academy.fonic.com
इसी का एक और सब डोमेन क्या हो सकता
है?com
या.fronic.com blogg.fonic.com
तो ये सारे blogg.fonic.com.fronic.com
academy.fronic.com ये सब जो है एक ही
पर्टिकुलर सेम ट्री के क्या है? पार्ट है
जो कि है डिफ्रon.com
सिंपल। तो यहां पर अ ग्रुप ऑफ डोमेनस दैट
शेयर द सेम नेम मतलब कि उसी पर्टिकुलर एक
ट्री के अंदर जितने भी मल्टीपल डोमेनस बन
रहे हैं,
ठीक है? उन सबका जो ग्रुप होता है, वह
ट्री कहलाता है। एज सिंपल एस दैट।
ठीक है? जैसे कि sales apple.com uk.com
finance.com
ये सब सेम सेम ट्री के अंदर है apple.com
तो ये पूरा एक ट्री कहलाता है। apple.com
ट्री। ये एक पूरा ट्री हो गया। एज सिंपल।
ठीक है? अब फॉरेस्ट को समझते हैं। द
हाईएस्ट लेवल। यह
सबसे हाई लेवल का सिक्योरिटी बाउंड्री है।
इट इज़ अ कलेक्शन ऑफ ट्रीज़। ट्रीज़ सो बहुत
सारे ट्रीज़ मिलके फॉरेस्ट बनाते हैं। इट
इज़ अ कलेक्शन ऑफ़ ट्रीज़। इफ Apple बाउट
अनदर कंपनी कॉल्ड बीट्स। मान लो Apple ने
एक और कंपनी को बाय कर ली जिसका नाम है
बीट्स। एक्चुअली Apple ने बीट्स को बाय
किया है पता है ना आपको कि यस ये रियलिटी
है। Apple हैव ऑलरेडी बाउट द बीट्स कंपनी।
तो अगर Apple ने किसी और कंपनी को मान लो
बाय किया बीट्स को। दे माइट पुट बोथ द
apple.com ट्री एंड द bts.com ट्री इंटू
वन बिग फॉरेस्ट। सो दे कैन टॉक टू ईच अदर।
तो एप्पल क्या करेगा कि इन दोनों ट्री को
apple.com ट्री और bts.com ट्री। इन दोनों
को एक साथ रख देगा। यानी दोनों ट्री हैं।
कलेक्शन ऑफ़ ट्री हो गया। और दोनों ने
मिलके एक फॉरेस्ट फॉर्म कर दिया ताकि वह
एक दूसरे से भी बात कर सके, कम्युनिकेट कर
सके। जैसे इसका एग्जांपल है कि आप Apple
का जो आउटलेट होता है जैसे दिल्ली में
आउटलेट है। अभी नोएडा में ओपन हुआ है।
मुंबई में Apple का आउटलेट है। अब ये जो
आउटलेट्स हैं ये सारे कंट्रोल होते हैं
Apple के सेंट्रलाइज्ड एक सर्वर से डोमेन
कंट्रोलर से। इसके जितने भी कंप्यूटरटर्स
हैं ना वह Apple के सेंट्रलाइज्ड एक डोमेन
कंट्रोलर से कंट्रोल होते हैं जो सर्वर
सेंट्रलाइज सर्वर है। एंड वहीं से इन सबको
मैनेज किया जाता है। तो अलग-अलग जगहों को
ट्री मानिए सबको एक साथ कंबाइन करके एक
साथ दोनों आपस में कम्युनिकेट अगर कर पा
रहे हैं तो वह फॉरेस्ट कहलाता है। बस
दैट्स इट। एज सिंपल
समझ में आया? ट्री एंड फॉरेस्ट का कासेप्ट
समझ में आया?
आर यू अंडरस्टैंडिंग गाइस?
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
आर यू गेटिंग?
इजी है ना?
ये बताइए इजी है। अभी तक आपको टफ लग रहा
है कि ईजी लग रहा है? मुझे यह बता दो।
जैसे अभी तक जो भी मैंने आपको बताया इट
सीम्स ईजी टू यू और इट सीम्स टफ टू यू।
सभी लोग आप रिप्लाई कीजिए।
तब तक मैं आता हूं। रिप्लाई कीजिए सभी
लोग। आई एम कमिंग।
ओके [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
सभी को समझ में आ गया? बढ़िया।
नॉट सो टफ इट्स इजी इजी तो अभी आपको इसलिए
लग रहा है क्योंकि मैं आपको इजी करके बता
रहा हूं। इजी बना के बता रहा हूं।
मुझे सिंपल वे में किसी ने पढ़ाया तो नहीं
था।
पढ़ाते-पढ़ाते आदत हो गई है। तो सिंपल वे
में बता देता हूं मैं।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
सर योर एप्रिसिएशन लेटर हैज़ मोटिवेटेड अ
लॉट। दैट्स ग्रेट रुद्र। बहुत बढ़िया।
अच्छी बात है। यू गाइस डिर्व दैट।
हम हम
हैंड्स ऑन से पहले भी अगर ईजी हो जा रहा
है तो इट्स अ ग्रेट थिंग। इट्स अ
इट्स अ ग्रेट अगर हैंड्स ऑन से पहले भी
आपका इजी हो रहा है।
इसी वजह से हम आते हैं। चलिए अच्छी बात
है। चलिए हम आगे की तरफ बढ़ते हैं।
नेक्स्ट वी आर मूविंग टू द नेक्स्ट। अब
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] यहां पे हम यहां
पे देखते हैं फिजिकल स्ट्रक्चर। जैसा
मैंने बोला था दो हार्डवेयर्स होते हैं
यहां पर दो तरह के हार्डवेयर की बात यहां
पर हम करते हैं एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी के अंदर
में व्हाइल द लॉजिकल स्ट्रक्चर इज़ हाउ यू
सी इट द फिजिकल स्ट्रक्चर इज़ वेयर द डेटा
एक्चुअली लिव्स एक्चुअली जो डेटा है कहां
पे स्टोर होता है फिजिकल स्ट्रक्चर का
मतलब सिंपल सा यहां पे है कि एक्चुअली
डेटा कहां स्टोर हो रही है यही यही मतलब
होता है तो दो तरह की चीजें होती है
फिजिकल स्ट्रक्चर में यहां पे एक होता है
डीसी डोमेन कंट्रोलर दूसरा होता है
साइट्स। दो तरह की चीजें होती है। डोमेन
कंट्रोलर एंड साइट्स डीसी। अब डोमेन
कंट्रोलर क्या होता है? दिस इज द सर्वर
दैट रंस द एडी सॉफ्टवेयर। डोमेन कंट्रोलर
वही होता है जो एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी के
सॉफ्टवेयर को रन करता है। दैट इज़ डोमेन
कंट्रोलर। सिंपल। इट होल्ड्स द डेटाबेस। अ
फाइल कॉल्ड NTDS डॉटdटी। एक फाइल होती है।
बेसिकली उस फाइल को भी गोली मारो। बस इतना
समझो कि यह डेटाबेस को कंटेन करता है। तो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] डोमेन कंट्रोलर
ये एक सर्वर है जो एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी के
सॉफ्टवेयर को रन करता है। यही वो सर्वर है
जो सब सब कुछ का मेन कॉज यही है। डोमेन
कंट्रोलर ही है भाई। मेन सर्वर वो एक एडी
सॉफ्टवेयर को रन करता है। इसके पास एक यह
एक डेटाबेस को कंटेन करता है। व्हेन यू
टाइप योर पासवर्ड योर कंप्यूटर सेंड्स इट
टू द डीसी टू आस्क इज इट करेक्ट?
तो जब भी एक लार्ज नेटवर्क
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] के अंदर में जब
भी आप कंप्यूटर पे एक बड़े नेटवर्क के
अंदर में कंप्यूटर पे पासवर्ड टाइप करते
हो तो यह डीसी को ही वो आपका रिक्वेस्ट
जाता है कि क्या यह सही है? है डोमेन
कंट्रोलर के पास ही जाता है। यह रिक्वेस्ट
गॉट इट? यह हमारी डीसी हो गया। अब आते हैं
साइट्स के ऊपर में। दी रिप्रेजेंट फिजिकल
लोकेशनेशंस।
ठीक है? दीज़ रिप्रेजेंट फिजिकल लोकेशनेशंस
लाइक एन ऑफिस इन न्यूयॉर्क एंड अनदर इन
लंदन। एडी यूज साइट्स टू मेक श्योर अ यूजर
इन लंदन टॉक्स टू अ लंदन सर्वर इंस्टेड ऑफ
वेटिंग फॉर अ स्लो सिग्नल सिग्नल फ्रॉम
न्यूयॉर्क सर्वर तो इसको आप आईएसपी
इंटरनेट सर्विस प्रोवाइडर्स के सर्वर्स की
तरह मान लीजिए जैसे कि आप google.com ओपन
करते हैं। इसको वैसे ही मान लीजिए नॉर्मल
ये नॉर्मल चीज है। google.com ओपन करते
हैं। तो डायरेक्ट आपकी रिक्वेस्ट Google
के यूएस सर्वर के पास तो नहीं जाती। बीच
में मल्टीपल राउटर्स होते हैं। उन राउटर्स
के थ्रू हो के जाती है। राइट? उनसे कनेक्ट
हो के जाती है क्योंकि आपका या आप ऐसे मान
लो इसको ऐसे मान लो कि जैसे आप कोई क्लाउड
वीpएस यूज़ कर रहे हो क्लाउड वीपीएस तो आप
क्लाउड वीपीएस में आपको रीजन चूज़ करने का
ऑप्शन आता है। जब आप Amazon को भी यूज़
करेंगे एडब्ल्यूएस तो वहां रीज़न सेलेक्ट
करने का ऑप्शन आता है। तो मोस्टली आपको
अगर आप इंडिया से हैं तो एशिया जो रीजन है
एशिया पेसिफिक या अगर कोई सिटी का नाम है
वहां पे जैसे मुंबई है ऐसा कोई मुंबई सिटी
का नाम दिया हुआ है तो उस एरिया को जो
आपके सबसे पास में पड़ता है उस रीजन के
सर्वर को अगर आप सेलेक्ट करते हैं तो वहां
से आपको एक अच्छी एफिशिएंट स्पीड भी मिलती
है एंड आपको वहां पे ज्यादा दिक्कतें फेस
नहीं करनी होती है। सिग्नल भी अच्छा आपको
मिल जाता है। तो बेटर स्पीड मिल जाती है।
कनेक्टिविटी अच्छी होती है। इसीलिए एडी जो
साइट्स का है ना वह यूज़ करता है टू
प्रोवाइड यहां पे जो यूज़र्स हैं मान लो जो
भी अह लाइक यूजर अगर मान लो कोई लंदन में
यूजर है तो लंदन वाले लंदन में जो सर्वर
है उससे कनेक्ट करें। इंडिया में कोई है
यूजर तो इंडिया वाले सर्वर से कनेक्ट
करें। न्यूयॉर्क में है तो न्यूयॉर्क वाले
सर्वर से कनेक्ट करें। ये साइट्स होती है।
बस सिंपल। ठीक है
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
सर। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] लाइव हैं आप
लेकिन नहीं देख पाऊंगा मैं। मैं आज
स्टार्ट करी है ट्रेनिंग में रिकॉर्डेड
वीडियोस को देख के हूं। ठीक है। थैंक यू
सर। आप बहुत अच्छा पढ़ाते हैं। यू आर
वेलकम विजय। आई एम ग्लैड।
ठीक है। अब डोमेन कंट्रोलर ही
कॉम्प्रोमाइज हो जाएगा तो सब कंप्रोमाइज
है। फिर तो डोमेन कंट्रोलर क्या बात कर
रहे हो? डोमेन कंट्रोलर ही कॉम्प्रोमाइज
हो जाएगा। फिर ये तो बहुत बड़ी लेवल की
अटैक हो गई ना एक एक
डोमेन पे एक बड़े नेटवर्क इंफ्रा पे। अब
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] हाउ इट वर्क्स द
स्पेशल सोर्स यहां कैसे यह काम करता है
इसको भी मैं समझ इसको भी मैं समझाता हूं
आपको।
ठीक है? एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी रियलाइज़ ऑन
थ्री मेन लैंग्वेजज़ या इसको बोलिए आप
प्रोटोकॉल्स टू वर्क। पूरी एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरी तीन मेन प्रोटोकॉल्स पे काम
करती है। तीन तीन तरह के मेन प्रोटोकॉल
होते हैं। ये तीनों बहुत इंपॉर्टेंट है।
ध्यान से देखिएगा। मैं आज की क्लास बहुत
धीरे-धीरे बता लेके जा रहा हूं। स्लो
थोड़ा लेकर जा रहा हूं क्योंकि स्लो
समझाऊंगा बेटर आपको समझ में आएगा।
जल्दी-जल्दी स्लाइड्स बस रीड कर दिया
करूंगा मैं तो फिर वह गड़बड़ है क्योंकि
मैं आपने देखा होगा कभी भी कोई भी क्लासेस
होती हैं किसी भी तरह की ट्रेनिंग होती है
स्लाइड्स को रीड करने का काम नहीं करता।
आपको मैं एक-एक चीज समझाता हूं और आज
थोड़ा और धीरे समझा रहा हूं ताकि आपको और
ज्यादा अच्छे समझ में आ जाए। बस मैं जो
बोल रहा हूं उस बात को दिमाग में ना फिट
करते रहना। एकदम समझते रहना। एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरी रियलाइज़ ऑन थ्री मेन
प्रोटोकॉल्स।
ठीक? [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] पहला है
डीएनएस। वही डीएनएस बाय व दूसरा एलडप लाइट
वेट डायरेक्टरी एक्सेस प्रोटोकॉल। तीसरा
है करबेरॉस।
तीन तरह की चीजों पे डिपेंड करता है। ये
डीएनएस के बारे में तो आप सब जानते होंगे।
इसके बारे में ज्यादा बताने की जरूरत नहीं
है। वही ये डोमेन नेम सिस्टम जो होता है
दिस इज़ द जीपीएस होता है। ये जीपीएस है।
इट हेल्प्स कंप्यूटर फाइंड वेयर द डोमेन
कंट्रोलर इज़ ऑन द नेटवर्क। ये
कंप्यूटरटर्स को ये फाइंड करने में मदद
करता है कि भैया डोमेन कंट्रोलर कहां पे
है? क्योंकि वही है डोमेन नेम आईपी
कन्वर्ज़ मतलब बेसिकली मशीन को फाइंड करने
का काम करता है कि भैया डोमेन कंट्रोलर
हमारे कहां है? जो हमारे मेन सर्वर हैं।
उन्हीं से तो सब काम है। उन्हीं से तो
सारा काम हमारा होगा। तो उसको फाइंड करने
के लिए यह हेल्प करता है कंप्यूटरटर्स की
डीआरएस। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
उसके बाद होता है हमारा एल डब। यह हमारा
लाइट वेट डायरेक्टरी एक्सेस प्रोटोकॉल कहा
जाता है। इट इज़ वन ऑफ द मोस्ट इंपॉर्टेंट
टॉपिक। एल्डप पे पूरी की पूरी एक कोर्स
डिज़ हो सकती है। तो ये उस टाइप का यह
प्रोटोकॉल है। एल्डप
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
द सर्च लैंग्वेज। इसको इजी वे में समझिए।
ये एक सर्च लैंग्वेज है। इट्स हाउ एडी
लुक्स अप इंफॉर्मेशन। एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी
इनेशन कैसे देख रहा है? कैसे मतलब उसको
निकाल रहा है? उस इंफॉर्मेशन को प्रोसेस
कर रहा है वो एल्डप होता है। जैसे फाइंड द
ईमेल एड्रेस फॉर जेन स्मिथ। अब कोई एंप्लई
है तो उसका हमें ईमेल आईडी फाइंड करना है
तो एल्डप के थ्रू आपका होगा। तो बेसिकली
लाइट वेट होता है यह एक डायरेक्टरी एक्सेस
प्रोटोकॉल डायरेक्टरीज को मतलब अलग-अलग
डायरेक्टरीज को एक्सेस करने का एक
प्रोटोकॉल है। बहुत लाइट वेट प्रोटोकॉल
है। बहुत ज्यादा यूज़फुल होता है। एक इडी
के अंदर यूज़ किया जा सकता है। एंड हम
अलग-अलग तरह की इंफॉर्मेशनेशन निकालने के
लिए इस प्रोटोकॉल का यूज़ करते हैं। बस
डायरेक्टरीज़ को सर्च करते हैं। डिफरेंट
टाइप्स ऑफ़ डायरेक्टरीज़, डिफरेंट कैटेगरीज़
ऑफ़ डायरेक्टरीज़ उसके अंदर की इनेशन को हम
सर्च करते हैं। उसके थ्रू इनेशन जो भी है
निकालते हैं। यह होता है एल्डर। तीसरा
होता है करबेरोस।
यह भी एक ऐसा टॉपिक है जिसके ऊपर पूरी
कोर्स बन सकती है। मतलब पूरी कोर्स एक
एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी तो अपने आप में कोर्स
है। उसके अंदर एल्डप यह अलग कोर्स बन सकता
है। करबोस ये अलग कोर्स बन सकता है। डीसी
डोमेन कंट्रोलर भी अलग कोर्स बन सकता है।
सच में तो करबोस क्या है? यह एक
ऑथेंटिकेशन सिस्टम है जिसमें टिकट सिस्टम
यूज़ किया जाता है। वंस यू लॉग इन करबेरस
गिव्स यू अ डिजिटल टिकट। सो यू डोंट हैव
टू कीप रीिटाइपिंग योर पासवर्ड एवरी टाइम
यू ओपन अ न्यू फाइल और प्रिंटर। अब
क्योंकि यहां एक बहुत बड़े नेटवर्क की बात
हो रही है। लार्ज नेटवर्क की बात हो रही
है। तो जब उस नेटवर्क में आप काम कर रहे
हैं, उस नेटवर्क में आप ऑपरेट कर रहे हैं
तो जब भी कोई प्रिंटर एक्सेस कर रहे हैं
या शेयर्ड फोल्डर एक्सेस करने की कोशिश कर
रहे हैं। शेयर डायरेक्टरी एक्सेस करने की
कोशिश कर रहे हैं एक नेटवर्क में तो आप
बार-बार पासवर्ड थोड़ी ना डालोगे आप। नहीं
डालोगे। तो इसलिए यहां पे करबेरॉस
ऑथेंटिकेशन का यूज किया जाता है। तो
एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी के अंदर में करबेरॉस
ऑथेंटिकेशन इज बीइंग यूज्ड जहां करबेरोस
के थ्रू ऑथेंटिकेट किया जाता है और यह
ऑथेंटिकेशन एक टिकट बेस्ड ऑथेंटिकेशन
कहलाता है। इसमें आपको एक टिकट दिया जाता
है। टिकट यह कैसी टिकट होती है? जैसे मैं
आपको बताता हूं। आप किसी
अ बार वगैरह में जाते हो। बार में हां
किसी बार वगैरह में जाते हो डांस बार
वगैरह में जाते हो या किसी इवेंट में इस
तरह का कोई बहुत डांस पार्टी वगैरह होती
है बड़ी पार्टी होती है उसमें जाते हो या
कोई एक जैसे एडवेंचर आइलैंड वगैरह या कोई
ऐसी ऐसी कोई पार्क होती है जहां पे बहुत
भीड़ होती है जाते हो वहां पे एडवेंचर
पार्कक्स जाते हो तो वहां जब जाते हो तो
पहला काम क्या करते हो वहां जाते हो तो एक
आप टिकट लेते हो राइट जाके टिकट खरीदते हो
टिकट लेते हो साथ ही में आपको एक रिस्ट
बैंड भी दिया जाता है अगर आपको पता हो या
आपको नहीं पता तो जान लीजिए एक रिस्ट बैंड
भी दिया जाता है उस रिस्ट बैंड को आपको
अपने हाथ में पहनना है थ्रू आउट जब तक आप
उस प्रेमाइस के अंदर जब तक कि आप उस
पर्टिकुलर जगह के अंदर रहेंगे अगर वो
रिस्ट बैंड नहीं होगी ना तो समझा जाएगा कि
यू आर नॉट ऑथराइज्ड पर्सन यह होता
और एक टिकट भी आप लेते हैं। तो जो टिकट
लेते हैं वह आपको क्या करता है कि हां
भैया आप एक जेन्युइन आदमी हैं। आपने टिकट
ले लिया। आपको ऑथेंटिकेट किया जाता है। आप
इस सुविधा का लाभ उठा सकते हैं। तो वैसे
ही करबस ऑथेंटिकेशन में राइट। हां। वैसे
ही करबस ऑथेंटिकेशन में यहां पे एक टिकट
आपको दिया जाता है करबस के तरफ से। और वह
टिकट के कारण आपको पासवर्ड नहीं डालना है
बार-बार। आप आराम से नेटवर्क के अंदर में
प्रिंटर्स को, शेयर फ़ोल्डर्स को,
डायरेक्टरीज़ को एक्सेस कर सकते हो। सिंपल
ऐज़ दैट। अब इसको भी हम समझेंगे कि ये काम
कैसे होता है।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
यहां तक सबको समझ में आ गया है। दीज़
थिंग्स आर क्लियर गाइज़ लॉजिकल स्ट्रक्चर
में ऑब्जेक्ट्स ओयूज़, डोमेन, ट्रीज़,
फॉरेस्ट एंड देन यहां पे फिजिकल में,
डोमेन कंट्रोलर, साइट्स एंड कैसे काम करता
है? तो तीन चीजें प्रोटोकॉल है डीएनएस,
एल्डप एंड करबेरस से। आर दिस क्लियर टू
यू?
प्लीज [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] बताइए
एवरीवन एवरीवन।
देखो ये गड़बड़ बात है यार। 50 से भी ज्यादा
लोग हैं बट रिप्लाई सब नहीं करते हैं। दिस
इज़ वेरी बैड। [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
[खांसने की आवाज़]
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
ठीक है? हां। लेकिन करबस इज़ द मोस्ट
पॉपुलर टिकट सिस्टम दैट इज़ बीइंग यूज़्ड
फॉर ऑथेंटिकेशन इन एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी।
हां, आज मैं काफी स्लो करा रहा हूं।
बिल्कुल सही बोला। आज मैं काफी स्लो करा
रहा हूं और स्लो ही चलेगा आज की क्लास। आज
की क्लास स्लो ही चलेगा।
ओके। अब हम आते हैं नेक्स्ट।
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] अब हम आते हैं
ग्रुप पॉलिसी के ऊपर में जिसको हम बॉस मोड
कहते हैं। यह हम बॉस मोड में आ चुके हैं।
ग्रुप पॉलिसी।
वन ऑफ द मोस्ट पावरफुल फीचर ऑफ एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरी इज ग्रुप पॉलिसी ऑब्जेक्ट्स।
जीपीओस ग्रुप पॉलिसी ऑब्जेक्ट्स जीपीओस
दिस अलाउस एन आईटी पर्सन टू चेंज द
सेटिंग्स फॉर थाउजेंड्स ऑफ कंप्यूटरटर्स
एंड एट वंस जैसे मैंने बोला कि ग्रुप्स
जो होते हैं जितने भी
जो भी मतलब ऑर्गेनाइजेशनल यूनिट के अंदर
होते हैं उनके ऊपर जब सेटिंग्स या पॉलिसीज
डाली जाती है तो एक दो नहीं थाउजेंड्स ऑफ
कंप्यूटरटर्स एंड यूज़र्स को इंपैक्ट
करेगी। तो सबकी एक साथ कोई सेटिंग चेंज
करनी हो, पॉलिसी सेट करनी हो, रूल सेट
करना हो तो आप सबकी
एक साथ में जीपीओस के थ्रू कर सकते हैं।
ग्रुप पॉलिसी ऑब्जेक्ट्स के थ्रू।
एग्जांपल मेक श्योर एव्री कंप्यूटर इन द
सेल्स डिपार्टमेंट हैज़ द कंपनी लोगो एज अ
वॉलपेपर एंड लॉक्स द स्क्रीन आफ्टर 5
मिनट्स ऑफ इनक्टिविटी। अब इस तरह की कोई
सेटिंग लगानी है कि सेल्स डिपार्टमेंट में
जितने भी कंप्यूटर हैं उनका वॉलपेपर
कंपनी का लोगो होना चाहिए और 5 मिनट के
इनक्टिविटी पर स्क्रीन लॉक हो जाना चाहिए।
तो यह इसके थ्रू हो सकती है। विदाउट एडी
यू वुड हैव टू वॉक टू एव्री डेस्क विथ एडी
यू क्लिक वन बटन। ऑब्वियस सी बात है। एडी
नहीं है तो हर कंप्यूटर पे जाके यह सेटिंग
करनी पड़ेगी एडी के साथ। बैड डन। सिंपल।
तो यहां पे अब मैं एक समराइज्ड व्यू दूं।
एक समरी दूं सबके अभी तक की। तो ऑब्जेक्ट
क्या होता है? अ सिंगल कांटेक्ट इन योर
फोन। ये ऑब्जेक्ट हो गया। ऑर्गेनाइजेशन
यूनिट क्या होता है? फोल्डर हो गया जैसे
वर्क कांटेक्ट्स।
ठीक है? कंपनी कांटेक्ट्स, स्कूल
कांटेक्ट्स, चाइल्डहुड फ्रेंड्स
कांटेक्ट्स। ये हो गया। डोमेन क्या होता
है? योर एंटायर फोन कांटेक्ट लिस्ट। आपके
फोन में पूरा जो कांटेक्ट लिस्ट है वो
डोमेन हो गया। फॉरेस्ट क्या होता है यहां
पे? मल्टीपल फोंस सिंक्ड टुगेदर। मल्टीपल
फोंस को एक साथ सिंक कर दिए तो वो फॉरेस्ट
हो गया और ट्री क्या हो गया यह मल्टीपल
फोन के कांटेक्ट्स मल्टीपल फोन के
कांटेक्ट्स एक साथ कर दिए ट्री हो गई और
मल्टीपल फोंस को एक साथ सिंक कर दिया वो
फॉरेस्ट हो गया डोमेन कंट्रोलर क्या हो
गया द एक्चुअल फोन हार्डवेयर स्टोरिंग द
डेटा डोमेन कंट्रोलर हो गया जो एक्चुअल
आपका फोन है जिसके अंदर एक्चुअली आप ये सब
डेटा स्टोर कर रहे हो वो फोन आपका डोमेन
कंट्रोलर हो गया तो ये एक एग्जांपल के
थ्रू आपको समझाया ताकि आपका क्लियर हो
समझ में आ गया होगा। राइट?
गॉट इट? अरे कलेक्शन ऑफ़ फ़ बहुत सारे जैसे
फोन की पूरी एक फोन की पूरी कांटेक्ट
लिस्ट जो हो गई वो आपका डोमेन हो गया।
बहुत सारे कांटेक्ट लिस्ट को एक साथ कर
दिया वो आपका ट्री हो गया। सिंपल।
और जब सारे फोंस को ही मर्ज कर दिया तो
फॉरेस्ट हो गई।
गॉट इट?
ठीक है।
हां, सारे फोंस एक साथ ट्री हो गए आपके।
और जब एक दूसरे से बात करने लगे, एक दूसरे
से कनेक्ट हो गया तो फॉरेस्ट हो गया। ठीक
है? ये समझ में आ गया इतना तक? क्लियर? अब
आगे चलते हैं।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अब देखो यहां पे दो चीज़ें यहां पे मैं
यहां पे एक चीज़ बताता हूं यहां पे।
अब इसके बाद हम आते हैं
टीजीटी एंड सेशन की पे। टीजीटी एंड सेशन
की पे हम इसके बारे में जानेंगे। टीजीटी
क्या होता है और सेशन की क्या होता है? अब
हम यहां पर करबेरॉस ऑथेंटिकेशन के ऊपर आ
रहे हैं कि जो मैंने आपको बताया था ना
करबेरॉस ऑथेंटिकेशन क्योंकि अभी तक हमने
जो भी पढ़ा उसमें हमने सब चीजें पढ़ ली
हैं। सब चीजें कांसेप्ट्स क्लियर हो गई
हैं। अब द मेन थिंग इज करबरोस ऑथेंटिकेशन।
ये एक एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी में बहुत
इंपॉर्टेंट होता है। यह टिकट सिस्टम
ऑथेंटिकेशन कैसे एक्चुअली काम करती है?
कैसे ऑथेंटिकेशन होती है? दिस इज़ वेरी
यूज़फुल। वेरी वेरीेंट। तो उसके अंदर ये
टीजीटी एंड सेशन की एक टर्म होता है। इसके
बारे में हम जानेंगे। लेकिन उसके पहले
इसके भी पहले हम यहां पे करबस ऑथेंटिकेशन
की इस चार्ट को देखते हैं और फिर हम इसके
अंदर की चीजों को समझेंगे।
ठीक है?
देखिए [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
सबसे पहले जानते हैं करबेरस क्या होता है?
तो करबेरस इज़ अ टिकट बेस्ड ऑथेंटिकेशन
प्रोटोकॉल। एक टिकट बेस्ड जो है
ऑथेंटिकेशन प्रोटोकॉल होता है। यूज्ड
मेनली इन Windows एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी
एनवायरमेंट्स। मेनली Windows के एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरी एनवायरमेंट में इसका यूज़ किया
जाता है। ये एक टिकट बेस्ड ऑथेंटिकेशन के
लिए प्रोटोकॉल है। बस और कुछ भी नहीं।
देखो होता क्या है? जो यूज़र्स ग्रुप्स हैं
आपके जो यूज़र्स हैं कंप्यूटरटर्स के
ग्रुप्स हैं
ये जो आपके रिसोर्स सर्वर है जहां से इनको
कोई चीज चाहिए होती है कोई भी चीज जो
रिक्वेस्ट ये करना चाहते हैं वो इनको
मिलती है लेकिन इस रिसोर्स सर्वर के तरफ
से तभी मिलती है जब इस यूजर या कंप्यूटर
को ऑथेंटिकेट कर दिया जाता है और
ऑथेंटिकेट कौन करता है हमारा सर्वर
Windows डोमेन कंट्रोलर डीसी हमारा डीसी
जो है वही तो ऑथेंटिकेट करता है
और इस पर्टिकुलर ऑथेंटिकेशन वाली जगह को
हम बोलते हैं केडीसी।
इसको हम बोलते हैं केडीसी।
ठीक है? अब यहां पे केडीसी जो होता है वो
दो चीजों से मिलके बना होता है।
एएस एंड टीजीएस।
केडीसी इज़ मेड अप ऑफ टू थिंग्स। एएस प्लस
टीजीएस। अब इन सबको समझने से पहले हम पहले
केडीसी और एएस और टीजीएस को पहले समझते
हैं कि एग्जैक्टली यह क्या होता है। तब हम
आएंगे टीजीटी और सेशन की जो मैंने पहले
अभी जो इसके पहले मैं यहां दिखा रहा था ना
आपको टीजीटी एंड सेशन की इस पे मैं अभी
इसलिए नहीं आया क्योंकि पहले हम इस
डायग्राम को समझेंगे देन हम उसके ऊपर
आएंगे।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
तो हम केडीसी और एएसटीसी टीजी टीजीसी को
हम यहां पे पहले समझते हैं। तो तीन चीजें
हैं केडीसी जो कि
एएस और टीजीएस से मिलके बनी है। केडीसी
आपका होता है की डिस्ट्रीब्यूशन सेंटर।
होता क्या है यह? द टिकट ऑफिस मेंशंड ऑन द
नेक्स्ट स्लाइड। यह एक टिकट ऑफिस है।
नेक्स्ट स्लाइड पे जो मेंशंड है। अब ये
टिकट ऑफिस क्या है? उसके लिए यहां पे
सिक्स स्टेप प्रोसेस को समझना पड़ेगा। तो
हम इस प्रोसेस को बाद में समझेंगे। अभी
रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है। बस इतना समझिए कि
यह एक टिकट ऑफिस है जहां से आप टिकट लेते
हो। जो आपका केडीसी होता है यह आपका क्या
है? एक टिकट ऑफिस है। जहां से आप टिकट
खरीदते हो। जैसे आप जाते हो थिएटर में
टिकट खरीदने। मान लो काउंटर से तो टिकट
खरीदा वो टिकट ऑफिस हो गई। किसी एडवेंचर
पार्क में जाते हो टिकट खरीदने उनके
काउंटर से वो टिकट ऑफिस हो गया। वो केडीसी
है।
ठीक है? अब एएस ऑथेंटिकेशन सर्विस द गाय
हु गिव्स यू द रिस्ट बैंड। अब यह
ऑथेंटिकेशन सर्विस है।
यहां पे एएस क्या है? वही बंदा जो आपको
रिस्ट बैंड देगा कि भाई रिस्ट बैंड लगा
लो। यह अगर खोलना मत। अगर यह नहीं बीच में
कहीं पे खुला मिला आपके हाथ में नहीं दिखा
तो आप यहां से निकाल दिए जाओगे। वो है
एएस। और आता है टीजीएस।
टिकट ग्रांटिंग सर्विस द गाय हु गिव्स यू
द राइड टिकट्स। यह एक्चुअल वह बंदा है जो
आपको टिकट दे रहा है। यानी कि जो टिकट
ऑफिस के अंदर बैठा हुआ है। तो अब देखा जाए
तो टिकट ऑफिस के अंदर ही रिस्ट बैंड वाला
बंदा भी खड़ा है और टिकट देने वाला भी
बंदा है। दोनों है। इसीलिए इन दोनों को
मिला के हमारा
क्या बन जाता है?
केडीसी बन जाता है। टिकट ऑफिस के अंदर में
टिकट देने वाला भी है और रिस्ट बैंड भी
देने वाला बंदा बैठा हुआ है। एज सिंपल एज
बस
तो यही हमारा केडीसी है। यही हमारा एएस
है। हमारा टीजीएस है। यानी KDC
इज इक्वल टू एएस
प्लस
टीजीएस
टिकट ग्रांटिंग सर्विस।
यही हमारे इस डायग्राम में यहां पर दिखा
है आपको समझ में आया केडीसी केडीसी का
मतलब केडीसी की डिस्ट्रीब्यूशन सेंटर
ऑथेंटिकेशन सर्विस और टिकट ग्रांटिंग
सर्विस तो की डिस्ट्रीब्यूशन सेंटर इज
इक्वल टू ऑथेंटिकेशन सर्विस प्लस टिकट
ग्रांटिंग सर्विस हमारा की केडीसी टिकट
ऑफिस है ऑथेंटिकेशन सर्विस हमारा भैया वही
है जो हमें क्या देता है टिकट देता है अ
टीजी टीजीएस क्या है? हमारा टिकट देता है।
एंड ऑथेंटिकेशन सर्विस जो है वो हमारा एएस
जो है रिस्ट बैंड देता है। ठीक है? बस
इतना समझ में आ गया?
गॉट इट।
ठीक है।
एक्चुअल अमेजिंग फ्री ट्रेनिंग का किसी को
कदर नहीं है। बिल्कुल सही बात है।
एक्चुअली सही बात है। निशा चौधरी यह तो
मैं पहले से बोलता हूं कि किसी को कदर
बिल्कुल भी नहीं होती है। फ्री में अगर आप
कोई चीज डिलीवर कर रहे हो ना तो उसकी कदर
बहुत कम लोगों को होती है। इनफैक्ट
रियलिटी है यह। अभी जैसे देखो एसओसी के
लिए ऐसा तो है नहीं कि हमारे पास 500 जो
फॉलोवर्स सब्सक्राइबर्स हैं उसमें सिर्फ
50 लोग इंटरेस्टेड हैं एसओसी में। ऐसा तो
मैं मान ही नहीं सकता। कम से कम 200 300
तो होने ही चाहिए। स्टिल उसमें भी नहीं
आते क्योंकि उनको रिकॉर्डिंग मिल रही है।
दैट्स द मेन डिफरेंस। रिकॉर्डिंग के भरोसे
हैं वो। बट एक दिन रिकॉर्डिंग गायब हो
जाएगी तो तब फिर दिक्कत होगी उनको।
कॉमिया प्लस कॉमटिया प्लस के लिए जाओ
बढ़िया रहेगा।
आई एम अ थ्रेट इंटेलिजेंस एनालिस्ट बट
व्हनेवर आई गेट टाइम आई सी यू। थैंक यू
एंड आई एम ग्लैड दैट
यू गाइस आर वाचिंग द वीडियोस एंड वाचिंग द
सेशंस एंड
एंड फाइंडिंग इट हेल्पफुल। तो बस देखते
रहिए, सीखते रहिए आप लोग।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
थैंक्स सर। वेलकम।
डिफ्रॉनिक्स सर जी खाना बना रहा हूं। साथ
में लेक्चर अटेंड कर रहा हूं। क्या बात है
निसार खाने के साथ-साथ लेक्चर इतनी
शिद्दत अगर सब में आ जाए तो क्या बात हो
जाए?
थैंक यू ब्रदर।
रिकॉर्डिंग अभी रहेगी। अभी तो जब तक यह
सेशन जब तक यह सीरीज खत्म नहीं। देखो हां
एक और चीज मैं आपको बता देता हूं। जब तक
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] ये सीरीज खत्म
नहीं हो रही है तब तक तो रिकॉर्डिंग फ्री
रहेगी। एंड आज Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम का
ये लास्ट क्लास है। इसके बाद से लinक्स
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम वाली क्लासेस शुरू हो
जाएंगी आपकी जो कि बहुत छोटी सी छोटी सी
ही पार्ट है। वह ज्यादा बड़ा पार्ट नहीं
है वो। एंड वी विल फिनिश दैट। उसके बाद से
आपका वही एसओसी का प्रैक्टिकल
डेमोंस्ट्रेशन और सब कुछ लैब्स एंड
एवरीथिंग जो इन मतलब इन एग्जीक्यूशन जो आप
देखेंगे
वो सब स्टार्ट होता है क्लासेस मुझे नहीं
लगता बचेंगे लinक्स के खत्म होने के बाद
तो आपकी कोर्स भी कंप्लीट हो जाएगी यू विल
बी रेडी फॉर द एल1 रोल अपने आपको एंड अगर
आप थर्ड ईयर फाइनल ईयर में है तो आपके लिए
तो यह गोल्डन चीज है
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] राइट
फिर L2 स्टार्ट नहीं L2 का ट्रेनिंग फ्री
में तो मैं नहीं लेकर आऊंगा। L2 और L3 की
ट्रेनिंग हम पेड रखेंगे। फ्री में L2 की
ट्रेनिंग लाने का कोई मतलब नहीं है। अब L1
में ही पता चल गया ना? नो नो कोई रिस्पांस
नहीं है। कुछ नहीं है। इवन 100 कमेंट्स
मैंने पहले 250 कमेंट का टारगेट रखा था।
फिर 200 किया। 150 किया। 100 किया। 100
कमेंट्स भी नहीं पूरे हो पा रहे हैं। सो
वी कैन नॉट एक्सपेक्ट एनीथिंग एल्स। तो वो
भी नहीं हो पा रहा तो वी विल बी रनिंग दैट
पेड। हम उसको पेड करेंगे। L2 और L3 उसमें
हम L1 को भी फिर से वापस से रिपीट कराएंगे
L2, L3 ट्रेनिंग में बट हम उसको पेड
रखेंगे। दैट विल नॉट बी फ्री एट ऑल। हां,
लेकिन अफोर्डेबल होगा। वह तो वह तो हम हर
ट्रेनिंग में करते हैं कि वह बहुत
अफोर्डेबल रखेंगे। उसके लिए बेफिक्र रहना
है आपको। वह तो हम हर ट्रेनिंग के लिए
करते हैं।
बिल्कुल बिल्कुल
ओके [गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
सुजॉय बोल रहे हैं सर आप हमारे
यूनिवर्सिटी के प्रोफेसर बन जाइए। भाई
प्रोफेसर बनने के लिए क्वालिफिकेशन चाहिए
होती है। ऐसे ही कोई प्रोफेसर नहीं बन
जाता। वो क्वालिफिकेशन मेरे पास नहीं है।
मास्टर्स चाहिए, कई पीएचडीस चाहिए,
नेट आई थिंक नेट वगैरह होता है उसको
क्वालीफाई करना होता है। तब जाके प्रोफेसर
बनते हैं। ऐसा तो नहीं बन सकते ना?
नहीं ऐसे डायरेक्ट ट्रेनिंग होगी।
चलिए [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] तो यहां
पर अब इस ऑथेंटिकेशन सिस्टम को हम थोड़ा
समझते हैं। वी आर गोइंग टू अंडरस्टैंड दिस
ऑथेंटिकेशन सिस्टम कि ये काम कैसे करती
है? इसको समझिएगा। एक यूजर सबसे पहले
टीजीटी रिक्वेस्ट करता है।
ठीक है? [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] एक
टीजीटी रिक्वेस्ट करता है। रिस्पांस में
डोमेन कंट्रोलर की तरफ से दो चीजें आती
हैं। टीजीटी प्लस सेशन की दो चीजें आती
है। ठीक है? उसके बाद यूजर अगेन टिकट के
लिए रिक्वेस्ट करता है प्लस ऑथराइजेशन।
ठीक है? दोनों के दोनों चीजें रिक्वेस्ट
करता है। ये अब रिस्पांस जो आता है डोमेन
कंट्रोलर से टिकट और स्टेट टिकट प्लस सेशन
की ये रिस्पांस में आता है। ठीक है? उसके
बाद यूजर जो है जब टिकट उसको मिल जाती है
एसेशन की मिल जाती है तो अब यूजर के पास
सब कुछ आ जाता है। टिकट इज द मेन थिंग जो
यूजर को चाहिए। तो टिकट जैसे ही मिलती है
तो अब यूजर जो है जो रिसोर्स सर्वर है
जहां से उसको जो रिसोर्स चाहिए जो चीजें
फच करनी है वो उसको रिक्वेस्ट करता है उसी
ओथ से जो उसको यहां मिला था डोमेन
कंट्रोलर से। ठीक है? उसी ओथ से यह सर्विस
को रिक्वेस्ट करता है। तो सर्वर जो
रिसोर्स सर्वर है उसको ऑथेंटिकेट कर देती
है एंड उसको वो रिसोर्स प्रोवाइड कर देती
है। बोलती है हां भैया ठीक है तुम बड़े
मेहनत करके आए हो यहां पे छह-छह स्टेप्स
को पूरा करके पूरा कर रहे हो तो तुम्हें
मैं दे देता हूं सर्विस क्योंकि तुम एक
ऑथेंटिक पर्सन लग रहे हो। अब यहां पे इसी
चीज को हमें समझना है। जो ये टीजीटी
रिक्वेस्ट हो रही है। ये सेशन की जो है ये
सब क्या है? टिकट्स ये सब क्या है? इसको
हम समझेंगे। टीजीटी सेशन की टीजीटी
रिक्वेस्ट किया रिस्पांस में टीजीटी प्लस
सेशन की आई ठीक है यह टिकट ग्रांटिंग टिकट
होती है यह मैं बताऊंगा यह फिर रिक्वेस्ट
टिकट किया ऑथ के साथ यहां टिकट मिल गई
सेशन की के साथ अब यह उसी ऑथ एंड
रिक्वेस्ट सर्विस के साथ रिक्वेस्ट भेजता
है और उसको सर्विस मिल जाती है। यह पूरा
का पूरा फंडा होता है। यहां पे आपने थ्री
वे हैंडशक तो यहां पे पढ़ा होगा थ्री वे
हैंडशक का। ये सिक्स वे हैंडशक है आपका।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
तो इस तरीके से ये पूरा का पूरा प्रोसेस
काम करता है। अब यहां पे हम समझते हैं ये
एग्जजेक्टली टीजीटी ये सब क्या चीज है। तो
चलिए बैक द बैक टू द स्लाइड्स प्रीवियस
स्लाइड्स। सबसे पहले टीजीटी को समझते हैं।
देन सेशन की को समझेंगे। टीजीटी इज़ टिकट
ग्रांटिंग टिकट। दो चीजें थी। याद रखिएगा।
एक आपका यहां पर टीजीएस था टिकट ग्रांटिंग
सर्विस जो आपको राइट की टिकट जो आपको देता
है और एक जो है यह
टीजीटी है टिकट ग्रांटिंग टिकट देखिए
समझिए क्या है व्हाट इट इज मास्टर रिस्ट
बैंड
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़][खांसने की आवाज़]
ये एक मास्टर रिस्ट बैंड है
फ्रॉम अ थीम पार्क मतलब कोई एडवेंचर पार्क
में गए हो तो वहां पे आपको एक एक रिस्ट
बैंड मिली लिए है तो वो मास्टर रिस्ट बैंड
टीजीटी आपका है।
योर मास्टर आइडेंटिटी प्रूफ प्रूफ्स यू आर
लॉग्ड इन इंक्रिप्टेड बाय की
डिस्ट्रीब्यूशन सेंटर।
यह प्रूफ होता है कि भैया आप आपकी
आइडेंटिटी है यह एंड आप लॉग्ड इन हैं एंड
आप का सब कुछ इंक्रिप्टेड है की
डिस्ट्रीब्यूशन सेंटर से केडीसी से।
सिंपल।
गॉट इट? अब
व्हाट्स इनसाइड
इसके अंदर क्या होता है? इसको हम इनवेलप
भी बोलते हैं। एक टीजीटी इनवेलप बोलते
हैं। एक सेशन की इनवेलप बोलते हैं। दो तरह
के ये इनवेलप्स होते हैं जो आपको मिलते
हैं। मतलब ये जो हमें रिस्पांस में मिल
रहा है ना हमने रिक्वेस्ट टीजीटी किया है।
ये जो रिस्पांस में हमें मिल रहा है। तो
एक टीजीटी इनवेलप होता है। इनवेलप नंबर वन
और एक सेशन की इनवेलप होता है। इनवेलप
नंबर टू। इसको हम इनवेलप बोलते हैं। तो
यहां पे इनसाइड में क्या होता है? इनवेलप
में एक यूजर आईडी होती है।
ठीक है? और एक एक्सपायरेशन टाइम होती है।
यूजर आईडी,
आईपी एड्रेस, एक्सपायरेशन टाइम। ये चीजें
इसके अंदर में डिटेल्स होती है। टीजीटी के
अंदर कि मतलब कब एक्सपायर होने वाला है।
ठीक है? आपका एड्रेस क्या है और आपका एक
आईडी यूजर आईडी क्या है? सिंपल। तो जैसे
ही आप किसी थीम पार्क एडवेंचर पार्क में
जाते हो तो आपसे आपसे एंट्री मान लो कराई
जा रही है तो आपसे बोला जा रहा है नाम
लिखो अपना तो नाम डाला। कहां से आए हो वो
लिखो एड्रेस डाल दिया। अच्छा 1 घंटे के
लिए आप इस एडवेंचर पार्क में एडवेंचर कर
सकते हो। तो वो टाइम एक्सपायरेशन टाइम डाल
दिया। तो 1 घंटे तक वैलिड होगी वो टिकट
आपकी। सिंपल
इजी तो है कहां टफ है यह टीजीटी है आपका
हाउ इट्स यूज्ड कैसे यूज़ होता है तो
क्लाइंट जो है
इसको शो करता है केडीसी को की
डिस्ट्रीब्यूशन सेंटर को टू गेट सर्विस
टिकट्स
सर्विस टिकट्स फॉर राइड्स या फाइल्स
सर्विस टिकट्स के लिए यह शो करता है फॉर
राइड्स और फाइल्स मतलब राइडिंग करने के
लिए या फिर फाइल्स फाइल्स को एक्सेस करने।
यहां राइडिंग का मतलब है फाइल्स को एक्सेस
करना। अगर टेक मतलब हम अगर सिंपल टेक्निकल
टर्म में समझे तो फाइल्स को जो एक्सेस
करना चाहता है यह बंदा तो उसके लिए हमें
केडीसी की डिस्ट्रीब्यूशन सेंटर को टिकट
दिखाया
और उसकी सर्विस टिकट लेने के लिए हमने या
फाइल्स को एक्सेस करने के लिए हमें परमिशन
मिल गई कि भैया ठीक है तुम सही हो ले लो
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है। अब उसी तरीके से सेशन
की होता है। सेशन की के बारे में आप में
से कई लोग तो जानते होंगे। ये वही सेशन की
और कुछ भी नहीं है। सीक्रेट हैंडशेक मतलब
अ यूनिक टेंपरेरी डिस्पोजेबल पासवर्ड फॉर
वन सिक्योर कन्वर्सेशन। कीप मैसेज
सीक्रेट। बस सिंपल सेशन की क्या होता है?
एक सेशन आपने बनाया। एक कम्युनिकेशन
स्टार्ट करी एंड बस उसमें एक सेशन की आपको
जनरेट हुई। जैसे ही कम्युनिकेशन स्टॉप
हुई, सेशन की जो है वह डिस्पोज हो गई।
दूसरी सेशन की स्टार्ट आपको जनरेट करके
मिलेगी दूसरे रिक्वेस्ट के लिए या दूसरे
सेशन के लिए। वही सेशन की होता है
क्रिप्टोग्राफिकली सिक्योर रखने के लिए
कम्युनिकेशन को बस वही चीज है। व्हाट्स
इंसाइड? तो एक सेशन की होता है जो कि
रैंडमली जनरेट होता है। हाउ इट इज़ यूज्ड?
तो क्लाइंट जो है इंक्रिप्टेड चैनल के
थ्रू एक सीक्रेट कोड मिलता है इंक्रिप्टेड
चैनल के थ्रू क्लाइंट को। बस वही तो
क्लाइंट एंड सर्वर बोथ रिसीव अ कॉपी टू
इंक्रिप्ट देयर प्राइवेट मैसेज। बस सिंपल।
मतलब क्लाइंट कोई एक सीक्रेट की हो गया
सेशन की और एक सर्वर का अपना वह मैसेज को
क्या कर सकते हैं? इंक्रिप्ट कर सकते हैं।
क्योंकि मैसेजेस तो इंक्रिप्ट होने चाहिए
ना भैया क्लाइंट के भी सर्वर के भी। तभी
तो कोई अटैकर उनको बीच में से उड़ा के
नहीं लेके जा सकता। वो वही चीज है। तो
देखा टारगेट टीजीटी इज़ इक्वल टू क्या है?
टीजीटी। आपकी आईडी है सेशन की योर
प्राइवेट कन्वर्सेशन कोड जो आपका बेसिकली
सीक्रेट कोड है क्रिप्टोग्राफिक कोड है
वही आपका सेशन के होता है तो यही दो चीजें
होती हैं टीजीटी और सेशन की अब इसमें और
भी चीजें हैं इसको अब हमें समझेंगे थोड़ा
डिटेल एक्सप्लेनेशन के साथ देखिए
टीजीटी इज योर मास्टरपास जैसा मैंने बताया
यह एक मास्टर पास है इन द थीम पार्क
एनालॉजी मैं थीम पार्क यहां पे एग्जांपल
ले रहा हूं।
थीम पार्क बोलो,
एडवेंचर पार्क बोल लो, कुछ भी बोल लो। दिस
इज द रिस्ट बैंड यू गेट एट द फ्रंट गेट।
एक थीम पार्क, एक एक एडवेंचर पार्क में जो
रिस्ट बैंड मिलती है, यह वही रिस्ट बैंड
है। [अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
सो, व्हाट इट कंटेंस? इसके अंदर यूजरनेम
होता है, आईपी एड्रेस होता है और एक वैलिड
अंटिल टाइम स्टैंप होता है। मतलब कि कितने
देर तक आपको अंदर वैलिडिटी है वो होता है।
सिंपल बताया मैंने। द सीक्रेट। द टीजीटी
इज़ इंक्रिप्टेड बाय द डोमेन कंट्रोलर
यूजिंग अ सीक्रेट की दैट ओनली द डोमेन
कंट्रोलर नोज़ जो वह टीजीटी होता है जो
आपका रिस्ट बैंड होता है उसको इंक्रिप्ट
कर दिया जाता है किसके द्वारा डोमेन
कंट्रोलर उसको इंक्रिप्ट करता है टीजीटी
को एक सीक्रेट की से जो कि सिर्फ और सिर्फ
डोमेन कंट्रोलर को ही पता है
व्हाई इट एक्सिस्ट बिकॉज़ इट इज़
इंक्रिप्टेड दिस वे यू कांट फेक इट और
एडिट इट क्योंकि अब क्योंकि की तो डोमेन
कंट्रोल के पास है तो आप उस रिस्क बैंड को
फेक नहीं कर सकते। किसी और को नहीं दे
सकते। उसमें कुछ चेंजेस करके किसी और को
नहीं दे सकते। किसी और को एंट्री नहीं करा
सकते। सो दैट यू कैन नॉट गेट अटैकर्स एंटर
इंटू योर नेटवर्क। सिंपल
व्हेन यू शो इट बैक टू द डीसी लेटर टू
आस्क टू एक्सेस टू अ फाइल, द डीसी
डिक्रिप्ट्स इट्स एंड सेज़ यप आई
रिकॉग्नाइज दिस। आई इशूड दिस टू जॉन 2
आवर्स एगो। सो ही इज स्टिल लेजिट। सिंपल
यही फंडा है कि जैसे आपने रिस्ट बैंड
बांधा
ठीक है अब मान लो कि आप थीम पार्क के
एडवेंचर पार्क से निकल गए कहीं बाहर और
वापस से आप घुसने की कोशिश कर रहे हो तो
आपको वही रेस्ट बैंड दिखाना है अरे भैया
मैं आया था यार देखो देखो रेस्ट बैंड अरे
अच्छा अच्छा हां हां जी भैया हमने तो इशू
किया था अरे हां तुम तो सही जेन्युइन बंदे
हो भाई रेस्ट बैंड है आ जाओ आ जाओ स्कैन
करके देखेगा कि अरे ये वही तो क्या करेगा
स्कैन करेगा वो बंदा स्कैन का मतलब वहां
डिक्रिप्ट कर रहा है तो डीसी उसको को
डिक्रिप्ट करेगा। डिक्रिप्ट करने के बाद
क्या बोलेगा कि हां सही है तुम
ऑथेंटिकेटेड बंदे हो। आ जाओ। दूसरे फाइल्स
भी एक्सेस कर सकते हो तुम। यूजर को बोल
देगा। दैट्स इट।
यही चीज़ होती है। सो दिस इज़ नोन एज
टीजीटीजी। अब आते हैं यहां पे सेशन की के
ऊपर। सेशन की इज़ लाइक अ टेंपरेरी
डिस्पोजेबल पासवर्ड क्रिएटेड जस्ट फॉर वन
कन्वर्सेशन। एक क्रिप्टोग्राफिकली
क्रिएटेड
यूनिक रैंडम टेंपरेरी कोड होता है जिसको
एक कन्वर्सेशन के लिए यूज में लिया जाता
है और यह हर कन्वर्सेशन में चेंज होता है
फॉर सिक्योरिटी रीज़ंस। अब देखो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
द प्रॉब्लम पहले हम प्रॉब्लम की बात करते
हैं। प्रेजेंट प्रेजेंट अच्छी बात है। इफ
यू एंड अ सर्वर टॉक ओवर द नेटवर्क द हैकर
माइट बी लिसनिंग। यू डोंट वांट टू यूज़ योर
रियल पासवर्ड टू लॉक दोज़ मैसेजेस।
द डीसी क्रिएट्स अ सेशन की। अब रियल
पासवर्ड्स को तो यूज़ नहीं करेंगे ना उस
कन्वर्सेशन को प्राइवेट रखने के लिए या
सिक्योर रखने के लिए। तो डीसी एक सेशन की
क्रिएट करता है। अ रैंडम स्ट्रिंग ऑफ
नंबर्स। इट सेंड्स वन कॉपी टू यू एंड अनदर
कॉपी टू द सर्वर। एक कॉपी आपको दे देगा।
दूसरा कॉपी सर्वर को दे देगा। नाउ यू एंड
द सर्वर कैन इंक्रिप्ट योर मैसेजेस यूजिंग
दिस रैंडम की। अब डीसी ने एक कॉपी सर्वर
को दे दिया। एक कॉपी किसको दे दिया भैया?
आपको दे दिया।
ठीक है? अब आप दोनों जब बात करेंगे तो आप
अपने मैसेजेस को इसी की से इंक्रिप्ट कर
दीजिए। लॉक कर दीजिए। टक टक लॉक हो गया।
इवन इफ अ हैकर स्टील्स द सेशन की इट
एक्सपायर्स इन अ फ्यू आवर्स। सो योर रियल
पासवर्ड रिमेन सेफ एंड अनटस्ट। अगर किसी
हैकर को मान लो सेशन की मिल भी गया तो
इसकी एक एक्सपायरी डेट एक एक्सपायरी टाइम
फिक्स होती है। दैट्स इट। एक्सपायर हो
गया। खत्म कहानी
डैमेज। दिस इज़ हाउ इट वर्क्स। यह टीजीटी
है एंड यह सेशन की होता है। कुछ लोग लीव
कर रहे हैं क्लास को। आई थिंक उनके दिमाग
से ऊपर से कुछ लोगों को जा रहा होगा। देखो
जो लोग बहुत
ज्यादा ध्यान से क्लास को नहीं करेंगे ना
उनके ऊपर से ही जाएगा।
एंड आई एम श्योर जो बहुत
ही ज्यादा कंसंट्रेट होके यह क्लास को अभी
कर रहे हैं उनको सब समझ में आ रहा होगा।
आई एम आई एम गारंटीड। आई एम गारंटिंग दिस।
मैं गारंटी दे रहा हूं इस बात की। लेकिन
जो ऐसे ही देखते हैं आते तो फिर तो ऊपर से
जाएगा भाई।
कितनी पानी पी लिया यार? पानी भी खत्म हुई
पूरी बोतल।
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़][अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़]
चलिए अच्छी बात है। आप लोग इधर ही हैं।
ग्लैड टू सी यू गाइस।
ये रियलिटी है अपनी। क्या कर सकते हैं?
इतनी अच्छी चीजें इतने अच्छे से मैं बता
रहा हूं फिर भी लोग नहीं है। एंड इसी को
पढ़ने के लिए लोग हजारों रुपए देंगे और
उसको पढ़ेंगे। वो भी इस तरीके से कोई
सिखाएगा नहीं उनको।
दिस इज वियर्ड थिंग बट दिस इज अ रियलिटी।
खैर कोई बात नहीं।
चलिए आगे की तरफ बढ़ते हैं। ये टिकट एंड
सेशन की समझ गए आप। अब यहां पर यह दोनों
जो टीजीटी है और यह सेशन की है। दोनों एक
साथ कैसे काम
कर रहे हैं?
ये दोनों कैसे एक साथ काम करते हैं? यह भी
हम जानते हैं। टीजीटी इसको हम टू इनवेलप
ट्रिक बोलते हैं। जैसा कि मैंने बताया
बताया था इस डायग्राम में कि दो चीजें
टीजीटी एंड सेशन की इसको इनवेलप बोलते
हैं। इनवेलप वन
यह इनवेलप लिखा है
और इनवेलप टू तो यहां पर टू इनवेलप ट्रिक
है यहां पे व्हेन द डोमेन कंट्रोलर सेंड्स
यू द रिस्पांस इन स्टेप टू ऑफ द नेक्स्ट
डायग्राम स्टेप टू में
ये [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] वाला
इट एक्चुअली सेंड्स टू इनवेलप्स एक इनवेलप
ए टीजीटी इनवेलप बी सेशन की
तो इनवेलप वन क्या होता है? दिस इज़ लॉक्ड
टीजीटी। यू कैन नॉट ओपन इट। यू जस्ट होल्ड
ऑन टू इट टू शो द सिक्योरिटी गार्ड लेटर।
टीजीटी को आप ओपन नहीं करोगे। इसको आप ऐसे
ही रखे रहोगे क्योंकि इसका तो लॉक उसके
पास होता है भैया। लॉक कर लॉक कर चुका
होता है वो जो आपका डीसी होता है उसको लॉक
कर चुका है। सेशन की दिस इज़ लॉक्ड इन अ की
डिराइव्ड फ्रॉम योर पासवर्ड। सिंस यू नो द
योर पासवर्ड। यू कैन ओपन दिस एंड द एंड
गेट द सेशन की इनसाइड। तो इसको आप ओपन कर
सकते हो क्योंकि आपको बताया ही था सेशन की
वाली जो
कीज़ होते हैं। वह सर्वर को भी भेजे जाते
हैं, आपको भी दिए जाते हैं। दैट्स इट।
ठीक? अब एक कॉमन मिस्टेक क्या होता है? अ
कॉमन मिस्टेक इज़ थिंकिंग द टीजीटी लेट्स
यू एक्सेस फाइल्स डायरेक्टली। ऐसा नहीं
है। टीजीटी से आप डायरेक्ट फाइल एक्सेस
नहीं कर सकते। इट डज़ नॉट। द टीजीटी ओनली
लेट्स यू टॉक टू द टिकट ऑफिस। टीजीटी आपको
टिकट ऑफिस से बात करने के लिए बस एलिजिबल
बनाता है। मतलब समझ रहे हो बात को? एक
एडवेंचर पार्क में घुस रहे हो गेट पर।
वहीं पर आपको एक रिस्ट बैंड दिया जा रहा
है, बांध दिया जा रहा है। मतलब कि आप अब
एलिजिबल हो आगे बढ़ने के लिए। अब आप टिकट
ऑफिस में जाके बात कर सकते हो। यू स्टिल
नीड अ सर्विस टिकट। स्टेप फोर इन योर
इमेज। स्टेप फोर यह वाला टिकट जो मेन टिकट
है हमारा वही सर्विस टिकट कहलाएगा। टू
एक्चुअली ओपन अ फोल्डर और यूज़ अ प्रिंटर।
तो एक्चुअली आप एडवेंचर पार्क में जाके
अलग-अलग राइट्स करने का या फोल्डर या
प्रिंटर को ओपन करने का शेयर करने का यह
सब एक्सेस करने का तो एक्चुअली आपको
सर्विस टिकट चाहिए तो टीजीटी आपको टिकट
ऑफिस तक पहुंचा रही है और टीजीटी क्या है
वो रिस्ट बैंड है जो आपको ऑथेंटिकेट कर
रही है वहां तक जाने के लिए और फिर वहां
से आपको मिलेगा सर्विस टिकट जो एक्चुअल
टिकट है एंड देन यू आर ऑथराइज्ड
यस यू कैन रिवाइज मैं तो बोलूंगा कि जितने
भी यहां पे यूज़र्स है। इस आज के सेशन को
रिवाइज जरूर कीजिएगा रिकॉर्डिंग देख के।
अभी तो जरूर पढ़िए। अभी तो आपको पढ़ना ही
है। लेकिन इसको रिवाइज भी करना है। आपका
और भी क्लियर हो जाएगा बस।
ठीक है? चलिए, यह आपको समझ में आ गया
होगा। अब यहां पे कुछ एक समरी करता हूं
मैं यहां पे। समरी टीजीटी रिस्ट बैंड है
सेशन की हैंडशक जो सेशन एस्टैब्लिश हो रही
है। हु मेक्स इट? तो टीजीटी को डोमेन
कंट्रोलर जो है वह बनाता है। यानी KDC की
डिस्ट्रीब्यूशन सेंटर वही डोमेन कंट्रोलर
सेशन की को भी डोमेन कंट्रोलर ही बनाता
है। हु कैन रीड इट ओनली द डोमेन कंट्रोलर।
टीजीटी को सिर्फ डोमेन कंट्रोलर पढ़ सकता
है। बट सीक्रेट की को दोनों ही पढ़ सकते
हैं। आप भी और सर्वर भी। पर्पस क्या होता
है? टू प्रूव यू आर ऑलरेडी लॉक्ड इन। यह
प्रूफ करना कि भैया मैं गेट के अंदर घुस
चुका हूं। अब टिकट काउंटर जाऊंगा। टू
इंक्रिप्ट द कन्वर्सेशन। सो नो वन कैन ईव
स्टॉप। इसका काम होता है सेशन की का
कन्वर्सेशन को इंक्रिप्ट कर देना। लाइफ
स्पैन क्या होती है? कुछ लिमिटेड टाइम के
लिए यूजली मतलब 10 घंटे 15 घंटे ऐसे होती
है। मतलब थोड़ी लिमिटेड थोड़ा टाइम ज्यादा
होता है इनका और सेशन की का बहुत शॉर्ट
होता है। जैसे ही एक कॉन्वर्सेशन एक्सपायर
खत्म बहुत शॉर्ट में होता है। तो ये
डिफरेंस है टीजीटी और सेशन की में इस
तरीके से। आई होप कि आपका यह समराइज हो
गया होगा जो मैंने अभी तक जो भी बताया
आपको टीजीटी और सेशन की के बारे में एंड
हम आगे बढ़ेंगे लेकिन अभी तक का मुझे
प्लीज ईमानदारी से बताइए सभी लोग सभी
चीजें क्लियर हो रही हैं दिमाग में फिट
बैठ रहा है वो हायरार्की आपको समझ में आ
रही है कि कौन किससे कैसे कनेक्टेड हैं
कैसे हम आगे जाते हैं कैसे हम गेट के अंदर
घुसते हैं तो अरिस्ट बैंड बांधते हैं
टीजीटी है टिकट ऑफिस जब हम पहुंचते हैं तो
टिकट ऑफिस कौन है भैया यहां जो मैंने
बताया था केडीसी की डिस्ट्रीब्यूशन सेंटर
वहां पे दो लोग जो आपको एक रिस्ट बैंड
देते हैं वही ऑथेंटिकेशन सर्विस वाले हैं।
जो रिस्ट बैंड जो आपको दे रहे हैं वही
ऑथेंटिकेशन सर्विस वाले हैं। एंड जो आपको
टिकट दे रहा है वो आपका टीजीएस है। इन
दोनों को मिला के टिकट ऑफिस हो गया आपका।
यह पूरा का पूरा फंडा है। आपको समझ में आ
गया होगा शायद।
रिवाइज करूंगी तो और अच्छे से आ जाएगा।
हां, देखो आज का टॉपिक कुछ ऐसा ही है कि
आपको रिवाइज करना ही पड़ेगा। इवन आपको अभी
भी समझ में आ रहा है ना स्टिल यू नीड टू
रिवाइज तब आपके दिमाग में परमानेंट बैठेगा
आज का टॉपिक ही ऐसा है बस
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
धीरे-धीरे दिखना शुरू हो गया हैं दिख
हां सर दिखना शुरू हो गया ना हां चलो
अच्छी बात है
ये करबोस एंड टीजीटी का प्रोसेस अगेन
रिवाइज करना पड़ेगा थोड़ा सा अब्दुल रहमान
आपको थोड़ा सा रिवाइज तो देखो हर बंदे को
करना पड़ेगा आज का क्लास
तो आपके दिमाग में बैठ जाएगा वो गारंटी के
साथ मैं बोल रहा हूं क्योंकि मैं जितना
एग्जांपल के थ्रू ईली ईजी में बता रहा हूं
ना अगर मैं टेक्निकल बताऊं तो आपको नहीं
समझ में आएगा यू विल नेवर अंडरस्टैंड अगर
मैं इसको टेक्निकल वे में बताता ना
टेक्निकल ओनली टर्म में तो आपको समझ ही
नहीं आएगा तभी मैं टेक्निकल आपको नहीं बता
रहा आपको मैं बता रहा हूं एक ऐसे तरीके से
कि आपको पता भी चले कि एक्चुअली केडीसी
क्या है एक्चुअली डोमेन कंट्रोलर क्या है?
सेशन की क्या है? टीजीटी क्या है? यह सब
और कैसे काम भी करते हैं? एंड आपको समझ
में आ जाए।
प्रदीप का ऑल डन ऑल क्लियर। क्या बात है।
बहुत अच्छी। बाकी लोगों का भी बहुत बढ़िया
है। आई नो काफी लोगों को समझ तो आ रहा है
बट रिवीजन की जरूरत है। तो यू हैव टू
रिवाइज़। तो अब ये पिक्चर क्लियर हो गई
आपकी। यह जो यहां प्रोसेस हो रहा है, यह
प्रोसेस आपको क्लियर हो गया। टीजीटी
रिक्वेस्ट किया, टीजीटी प्लस सेशन की आई।
फिर रिक्वेस्ट टिकट प्लस ऑथ फिर टिकट प्लस
सेशन किया गया। फिर रिक्वेस्ट सर्विस किया
ऑथ के साथ एंड देन उसको सर्विस मिल गई। यह
पूरा करबोरेस ऑथेंटिकेशन काम करता है।
राइट
डिफ्रॉनिक्स अच्छा सर आई एम कीपिंग माय
प्रॉमिस फ्रॉम द फर्स्ट वीडियो टू कंप्लीट
दिस एसओसी कोर्स एंड गेट अ जॉब सर बट
प्लीज डोंट डिस्कंटिन्यू दिस कोर्स
दिस मी नहीं डिस्कंटिन्यू तो कोर्स नहीं
होगा। डिस्कंटिन्यू कहां से होगा?
डिस्कंटिन्यू नहीं होगा। लेटर ऑन बाद में
कोर्स जब एंड हो जाएगी उसके कुछ टाइम के
बाद इनको हम पेड कर देंगे। सोचा है करने
का क्योंकि हमें रिस्पांस अगर मिलता रहेगा
तो हम नहीं करेंगे पेड। बस सिंपल
ओके दैट्स व्हाई आई कम केम टू
डिफ्रॉनिक्स। दैट्स ग्रेट अब्दुल। ओके।
चलिए
अब यहां पर आते हैं। देखो जो कोवेरस
ऑथेंटिकेशन हमने पढ़ा ना उसी का ये एक
सिंपलीफाइड
डायग्राम है जो मैं आपको बस थोड़ा सा
जल्दी-जल्दी बता देता हूं। जो हमने ऑलरेडी
पढ़ लिया है। वही चीज है। बस थोड़ा सा
समझा देता हूं। जैसे एक यूजर होते हैं।
यूज़र्स हैं। ठीक है? सिंपल यूज़र्स होते
हैं।
तो क्या होती है? टिकट ग्रांटिंग सर्विस
होती है टीजीएस देन ऑथेंटिकेशन सर्विस
होती है एएस देन कर्वेस का अपना डेटाबेस
जो होता है और सर्विस सर्वर जो सर्विस
प्रोवाइडर तो यूजर सेंड्स ऑथेंटिकेशन
रिक्वेस्ट पहले नंबर पे क्या होता है यूजर
ऑथेंटिकेशन रिक्वेस्ट भेजता है दूसरे पे
करोस के डेटाबेस में ये चेक होती है कि इफ
यूजर एक्सिस्ट इन द डेटाबेस तीसरे स्टेप
में अगर यूजर एक्सिस्ट करता है बढ़िया है
तो टीजीटी इशू की जाती है उसके साथ सेशन
की भी जाता है यहां पे नहीं लिखा हुआ है
बट ये आपको पहले ही मैंने इस वाले में बता
दिया है कि सेशन की टीजीटी के साथ यहां पे
जाती है। इशू होती है। अब यूज़र्स चौथे
स्टेप में यूज़र्स सेंड्स रिक्वेस्ट टू
टीजीएस।
अब यह सेशन टीजीएस के पास भेजता है जो यह
सेशन की आ रही है। तो अब रिक्वेस्ट टिकट
के लिए टिकट की रिक्वेस्ट के लिए यह
टीजीएस को रिक्वेस्ट भेजता है। टीजीएस
चेकक्स इफ यूजर एक्सिस्ट इन डेट। अब
टीडीएस टीजीएस जो है टिकट ग्रांटिंग
सर्विस वापस से चेक करता है कि ये उनके
डेटाबेस में एक्चुअली यूजर ये भी है कि
नहीं है। अगर है बहुत बढ़िया बात है।
टीजीएस इशूज़ सर्विस टिकट तब टीजीएस जो है
उसको एक्चुअल टिकट इशू कर देता है। यानी
कि यह जो टिकट इशू हुई है यह टीजीएस के
तरफ से इशू हुई है। आफ्टर चेकिंग इफ द
यूजर एक्सिस्ट इन द डेटाबेस। जब यूजर ने
टिकट के लिए रिक्वेस्ट किया था ऑथ्स के
साथ। अब यूजर कांटेक्ट्स डिजायर्ड सर्विस
सर्वर विद सर्विस टिकट। अब यूजर उस सर्वर
को कांटेक्ट करता है जहां से उसको जो
सर्विस चाहिए उस सर्विस टिकट के साथ एंड
उसको एक्सेस ग्रांट हो जाता है। वो एक्सेस
ग्रांट कर एंड दे कैन एक्सेस द सर्विस एज
सिंपल एज दैट।
ठीक है? नटखट गैज ऑल ओके बट आई डोंट
अंडरस्टैंड। कोई बात नहीं रिवाइज करो
अंडरस्टैंड हो जाएगा टेंशन नहीं लेने का
ठीक है एक बार और रिवाइज कीजिएगा हो जाएगा
सर विदाउट डिग्री जस्ट हैंड्स ऑन
प्रैक्टिस में जॉब क्रैक कर सकता हूं ये
डिपेंड करता है कंपनी के ऊपर ये ऐसे कैसे
बता सकते हैं कंपनी के ऊपर डिपेंड करता है
कि विदाउट डिग्री वो लेने को रेडी है या
नहीं है हम तो हमारे डेफ्रॉनिक्स के जो भी
हायरिंग करते हैं उसमें डिग्री का कोई
मेंशन नहीं करते
डिग्री ना हो स्किल्ड हो बंदा
तो चलेगा कोई दिक्कत नहीं है। अभी हमारा
जो डेवलपर है जो फुल स्टक डेवलपर है उसकी
कोई टेक डिग्री उसके पास नहीं है। नॉन टेक
डिग्री है उसके पास। बट स्टिल ही इज़
वर्किंग वि द डिफ्रॉनिक बिकॉज़ ही इज़ वेरी
टैलेंटेड पर्सन। तो टैलेंट के बेसिस पर हम
हायर करते हैं। हम डिग्री देख के हायर
नहीं करते। लेकिन सारी कंपनी ऐसा नहीं
करती ना। डिफ्रॉनिक्स ऐसा करती है और आगे
भी करती रहेगी।
[अचानक ज़ोर से सांस लेने की आवाज़][गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
ठीक है? यह समझ में आपका आ गया होगा यह
सारी चीजें। अब कर्वेस ऑथेंटिकेशन को यहां
पे थोड़ा सा एक्सप्लेनेशन वे में समझते
हैं। ये सारी चीजें तो आपकी क्लियर हो गई।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
एक्सप्लेनेशन वे में। ठीक है? पहले जो
डायग्राम्स थे उन्होंने कर्वस को
एक्सप्लेन किया व्हिच इज़ अ सिक्योरिटी
गार्ड ऑफ़ एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी। यह
सिक्योरिटी गार्ड है भैया। एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरी का हमारा। टू मेक इट सिंपल।
लेट्स इमेजिन यू आर गोइंग टू अ मैसिव थीम
पार्क। मतलब एक एडवेंचर पार्क में जा रहे
हैं। यही चीजें जो मैंने आपको बताया ना
वही चीजें हैं। इन दिस थीम पार्क यू डोंट
कैरी कैश और योर आईडी टू एव्री राइड। हर
जो भी आप एडवेंचर पार्क में जाते हो जो भी
राइड करने जाओगे कोई चीज तो हर बार थोड़ी
ना आईडी दिखाओगे या अपनी आप वो करोगे तो
आपको एक टिकट खरीदना है। बस सिंपल इंस्टीड
यू यूज़ टिकट्स। आप टिकट्स बाय करते हो।
एज़ सिंपल एज दैट। तो तीन प्लेयर हैं यहां
पे। आप क्लाइंट हो। द टिकट ऑफिस जो कि
केडीसी आपका हो गया डोमेन कंट्रोलर और
राइड जो रिसोर्स सर्वर है बस द पर्सन
ट्राइंग टू लॉग इन एंड यूज़ अ फाइल प्रिंटर
जो कि आप है एज अ क्लाइंट पहले यह हो गया
दूसरा द ओनली प्लेस दैट नोज़ योर पासवर्ड
डोमेन कंट्रोलर ही को पता है आपका पासवर्ड
एंड द फाइल सर्वर प्रिंटर यू वांट टू यूज़
जो रिसोर्सेज आप यूज़ करना चाहते हैं। बस
यही तीन चीजें होती हैं। और जो ये तीन
टर्म्स हैं ये पहले ही डिस्कस कर दिया
मैंने केडीसी एएस और टीजीएस क्या होते
हैं? दैट्स इट। यह पूरा का पूरा आपका यह
टर्म होता है। अब आगे की तरफ चलते हैं
सिक्स स्टेप प्रोसेस पे।
अब ये जो पूरी स्टेप मैंने बताया सिक्स
स्टेप ये पहले देखो ये सिक्स स्टेप
प्रोसेस था ना पहला स्टेप रिक्वेस्ट।
दूसरा टीजीटी सेशन की तीसरा चौथा पांचवा
छठा। इसी स्टेप को हम एक डिटेल
एक्सप्लेनेशन के साथ पढ़ रहे हैं। अभी तो
डायग्राम्स में और चीजों में बताया मैंने
आपको यह। अब मैं इसी को डिटेल
एक्सप्लेनेशन के साथ बताऊंगा कि यह छह
स्टेप में एक्चुअली हो क्या रहा है और
आपको और भी ज्यादा क्लियर हो जाएगा। और भी
ज्यादा क्लेरिटी मिलेगी। यही मेन चीज है।
ओके? ठीक है। लेट मी फिल सम वाटर एंड देन
ओके अब तो भूख भी लग गई यार। ओके
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
चलिए।
एक सिक्स्थ स्टेप प्रोसेस को समझते हैं।
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
क्लास के बाद ही खाएंगे ना।
पहले तो क्लास ही करेंगे। फिर ही तो
खाएंगे। [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
चलो। [खांसने की आवाज़]
तो पहले स्टेप वन एंड टू को डील करते हैं।
गेटिंग योर एंट्री पास। यह स्टेप वन और टू
है। स्टेप वन और टू में क्या होता है?
टीजीटी और सेशन की की बारी आती है। जैसा
कि पहले ही बताया था। तो यू टाइप योर
पासवर्ड। [खांसने की आवाज़]
टेक्निकल अप्रोच भी देख रहे हैं।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यू टाइप योर
पासवर्ड। योर कंप्यूटर सेंड सम मैसेज टू द
टिकट ऑफिस सेइंग हे आई एम जॉन। हियर इज़
माय प्रूफ ऑफ आइडेंटिटी। अब आते हैं। यह
टीजीटी के लिए आपने रिक्वेस्ट किया है।
ठीक है? पहले स्टेप में। दूसरे स्टेप में
टीजीटी प्लस एसए द टिकट ऑफ़िस चेक्स इट्स
डेटाबेस इफ़ [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] यू
आर लेजिट इट गिव्स यू अ टीजीटी टिकट
ग्रांटिंग टिकट टिकट ऑफिस फिर आपका टेक
थाटा अगर आप लेजिट है तो यहां पे अब वो
क्या करेगा बोलेगा कि हां ठीक है भैया
डेटाबेस में आप हो ठीक है चलेगा दैट्स इट
अब आपको वो टीजीटी एक टीजीटी इशू कर देगा
ठीक है एनालॉजी क्या है यहां पे दिस इज़
लाइक अ हैंड स्टैंप और और अ रिस्ट बैंड
जैसा मैंने पहले ही बताया इट डज़ नॉट लेट
यू राइड येट बट इट प्रूव्स यू पेड टू गेट
इंटू द पार्क। यह एक रिस्ट बैंड आपको दे
देता है जो आपको अंदर जाके
[खांसने की आवाज़][गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
पार्क में अंदर जाने के लिए आपको अलऊ कर
रहा है। राइट्स अभी भी आप नहीं ले सकते।
टिकट लगेगा उसके लिए तो अंदर जाने के लिए
अलऊ कर देता है। तो पहले दो ऑप्शन में एक
तो टीजीटी रिक्वेस्ट हो गई और टीजीटी प्लस
सेशन की जो कि मैंने पहले यहां पे बताया
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] था। पहला दो
स्टेप ये कंप्लीट हो गया। ये दोनों स्टेप।
अब तीसरे और चौथे स्टेप की बढ़ते हैं।
गेटिंग योर राइड टिकट्स। अब वह राइडिंग जो
आप करोगे उसके अंदर एडवेंचर पार्क में
जाके उसके लिए टिकट चाहिए। वो टिकट अब
लेना है थर्ड एंड फोर्थ स्टेप में। तो
रिक्वेस्ट टिकट प्लस ऑथ। रिक्वेस्ट टिकट
प्लस ऑथ मतलब क्या है? यू वांट टू ओपन अ
फाइनेंस स्प्रेडशीट।
मान लो आप फाइनेंस का एक स्प्रेडशीट ओपन
करना चाहते हो कंप्यूटर
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] पे। यू शो द
टिकट ऑफिस योर रिस्ट बैंड एंड से आई वुड
लाइक टू राइट द फाइनेंस रोलर कोस्टर
प्लीज। तुम आपने क्या किया? आपने टीजी जो
टिकट ऑफिस है
उसको क्या किया? शो किया अपनी टीजीटी कि
भैया ये रहा देखो देखो देखो रियलिस्ट बैंड
टीजीटी है मेरे पास। मैं फाइनेंस वाले
स्प्रेडशीट को एक्सेस करना चाहता हूं। समझ
में आ रहा है? एक्सेस चाहिए मुझे। उसके
बाद फोर्थ स्टेप में टिकट प्लस सेशन की। द
टिकट ऑफिस। आपने टिकट ऑफिस से यह चीज़
बोली। अब टिकट ऑफिस चेक्स इफ यू आर अलाउड
ऑन दैट राइट। अब टिकट ऑफिस पहले चेक करेगा
कि आप ऑथराइज़्ड हो भी कि नहीं फाइनेंसियल
स्प्रे स्प्रेडशीट को एक्सेस करने के लिए।
अगर ऑथराइज़ नहीं हो तो वहीं से दफा हो जाओ
निकल जाओ। ऑथोराइज़्ड हो फिर हम आगे की बात
करते हैं। इफ यस इट हैंड्स यू अ सर्विस
टिकट। अगर आप ऑथराइज़्ड हो तभी आपको वो
टिकट देगा। जैसे कि कोई बच्चा चला गया और
किसी बड़े से एक अह एक एक कोई झूला है उस
पे झूलने को जिद करने लगा। कोई बड़ा सा
कोई कोई बड़ा सा झूला है तो उस पे ऑथराइज
नहीं है। उस पे अगर लिखा है कि 18 प्लस
होने वाले ही 18 प्लस या 15 प्लस लोग हैं।
वही अलाउड है इस झूले पे। वो कोई 10 साल
का बच्चा चला गया। तो वो तो पहले देखेगा
ना कि बच्चा एक्चुअली ऑथराइज्ड है कि नहीं
होगा। अगर नहीं है तो बच्चे को बोलेगा
भागो। अगर है तब जाके उसको एक टिकट दे
देगा। लो बच्चे तुम टिकट लो जाओ झूलो मजे
करो। तो अब टिकट मिल गई है तो दिस इज़ अ
स्पेसिफिक टिकट जस्ट फॉर दैट वन राइड। तो
बच्चे को जो टिकट मिली है वो उससे बस वही
झूला झूल सकता है और कुछ नहीं कर सकता
दूसरे झूले पे नहीं जा सकता वो वही सेम
चीज है यहां पे फाइनेंस वाले जो
स्प्रेडशीट है बस उसी को ये यूजर एक्सेस
कर सकता है जो टिकट उसको मिली है उसके
थ्रू एज सिंपल एज दैट समझ में आया ये चार
स्टेप्स उसके बाद आते हैं पांचवा और छठा
स्टेप रिक्वेस्ट सर्विस प्लस ऑथ एंड सर्वर
ऑथेंटिकेशन तो यू गो टू द फाइनेंस सर्वर
एंड हैंड्स ओवर योर सर्विस टिकेट अब
क्योंकि आपको फाइनेंस स्प्रेड स्प्रेडशीट
एक्सेस करना है तो आप फाइनेंस वाले सर्वर
के पास जाओगे क्योंकि उसी के पास वो
स्प्रेडशीट है। टेक्निकल आईटी सर्वर के
पास आईटी के से रिलेटेड फाइल्स हैं।
सिक्योरिटी सर्वर्स के पास सिक्योरिटी
रिलेटेड फाइल्स है। तो फाइनेंस वाले के
पास सर्वर के पास बोले कि भैया ये टिकट
है। मतलब कि फाइनेंस सर्वर कौन है? वो
झूला वाला है। झूले वाले के पास गया अरे
झूला ये टिकट लो। अब सर्वर ऑथेंटिकेशन द
सर्वर लुक्स एट द टिकट। झूला वाला टिकट को
देखता है। सीज़ इट वाज़ साइन बाय द ऑफिशियल
टिकट ऑफिस। देखता है कि हां यार यह तो
टिकट ऑफिस वाले ही हैं। उसी से खरीदा हुआ
है। एंड सेज़ वेलकम अब्रॉड। यू कैन नाउ
फ्लाई ऑन द झूला। नाउ यू कैन सी द फाइल्स।
और बोलता है कि भैया आ जाओ झूले झूलो। कोई
टेंशन नहीं है। मस्त मजे में झूलो क्योंकि
टिकट है। ऑथेंटिकेट हो चुकी है। दैट्स इट।
यही तो पूरा का पूरा फंडा है। पूरा का
पूरा स्टेप है। अब यह स्टेप आपको समझ में
आ गया छह के छह स्टेप। अब तो समझ में आया?
यह ज थीम पार्क जो एडवेंचर पार्क है उसकी
मदद से आपको सब कुछ समझ में आ गया। एज
सिंपल एज दैट
एवरीवन अंडरस्टैंड प्लीज बताइए।
समझ आ गया? [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
अब इसको मैं समराइज कर देता हूं।
रिक्वेस्ट टीजीटी फर्स्ट स्टेप आप जाते हो
एक एडवेंचर पार्क में वहां पर बोलते हो कि
भैया क्या बोलते हो
टिकट मतलब टिकट ऑफिस को ऐसा बोलते हो कि
भैया यह मेरी प्रूफ ऑफ आइडेंटिटी है मतलब
आप अपना पासवर्ड टाइप कर रहे हो तो आप
अपनी आईडी प्रूफ ऑफ आइडेंटिटी दिखा रहे हो
कि भैया देखो यह मेरी प्रूफ ऑफ आइडेंटिटी
है फर्स्ट स्टेप दूसरा स्टेप अब वहां पे
जो टिकट ऑफिस है वो चेक करेगा अपने
डेटाबेस में कि अच्छा तुम ही हो सच में हो
ऐसा हो क्या तो आपको वो टीजीटी दे देगा
टीजीटी प्लस सेशन की टीजीटी दे दिया कि
हां भाई ठीक है तुम तो सही बंदे लग रहे हो
तुम्हारे पास प्रूफ ऑफ आइडेंटिटी है या
रिस्ट ये जो रिस्ट बैंड है वो है मान लो
रिस्ट बैंड वो आपके पास है आपने रिस्टंड
दिखाया हां ठीक है अब आ जाते तीसरे स्टेप
पे कि अब तुम कहां गए अब तुम गए फाइनेंस
वाले स्प्रेडशीट तुम ओपन करना चाहते हो तो
अब गए टिकट ऑफिस के पास और उसके बाद बोला
कि मुझे फाइनेंस वाली डिपार्टमेंट ओपन
करनी है तो टिकट ऑफिस ने बोला कि अच्छा
ठीक है मैं देख लेता हूं तुम एलिजिबल हो
कि नहीं 18 प्लस हो कि नहीं हो तो ठीक है
जाओ ये लो टिकट और जाओ तुम एक्सेस करो
पांचवें में क्या होता है कि आप उस
पर्टिकुलर सर्वर के पास जाते हो झूले वाले
के पास बोलते हो कि भैया टिकट है यार झुला
दो तो बोलता है अच्छा ठीक है ना उसने चेक
किया छठे स्टेप में अरे सब सही है बढ़िया
झूल लो दैट्स इट हो गया
गॉट इट [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
डड यू गेट इट
एवरीवन अंडर अंडरस्टुड सभी लोग समझ चुके
हैं? एक बार बताइए फटाफट बताइए।
एवरीवन अंडरस्टुड
ओके गॉट इट। गॉट इट।
बहुत बढ़िया।
फेक आईडी से आकर यार पता नहीं क्या समझते
हैं यार मैं समझ नहीं आता रियल आईडी से
आने की हिम्मत क्यों नहीं होती लोगों को
रियल आईडी दो अपनी नंबर दो तब तो पता चले
कि कौन किससे पाला पड़ा है आपका
ठीक है चलिए अच्छी बात है अब यहां पे
व्हाई डू वी डू दिस हम ये सब क्यों कर रहे
हैं यार ये सब कचरा कचरा क्यों कर रहे हैं
व्हाई वी आर डूइंग दिस तो सिक्योरिटी के
लिए स्पीड के लिए बस सिंपल ये सिक्योरिटी
के लिए होता है सिक्योर करने के लिए और
स्पीड के लिए मतलब कि मतलब आपको बार-बार
पासवर्ड ना डालना पड़े। सिक्योरिटी योर
एक्चुअल पासवर्ड इज़ ओनली सेंट वंस आफ्टर
दैट ओनली टिकट्स मूव अक्रॉस द नेटवर्क।
आपका एक्चुअल पासवर्ड एक बार ही आप
ऑथेंटिकेशन में फर्स्ट स्टेप में यूज़ करते
हो जहां टाइप करते हो पासवर्ड। उसके बाद
सिर्फ टिकट्स का यूज़ होता है नेटवर्क के
अंदर में। इफ अ हैकर इज़ लिसनिंग दे कांट
स्टील योर पासवर्ड बिकॉज़ दे ओनली सी
टेंपररी टिकट्स। तो अगर हैकर
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] घूम भी रहा है
उसको बस टिकट ही मिलेंगे। पासवर्ड्स नहीं
मिल पाएंगे। दैट्स इट। उसके बाद स्पीड वंस
यू हैव द रिस्ट बैंड इन स्टेप टू यू डू यू
डू यू डू यू हैव टू टाइप द पासवर्ड। स्पीड
मतलब बार-बार पासवर्ड टाइप नहीं करना
पड़ेगा। एंड जस्ट इट। बार-बार पासवर्ड
टाइप नहीं करना पड़ेगा। आपका चलता रहेगा।
ओके।
अब यहां पे कुछ एडी अटैक्स की बात कर लेते
हैं। बस थोड़े से और हैं। उसके बाद यह
आपका खत्म हो जाएगा। तो एक अटैक होता है
पास द हैश अटैक। दिस इज अ काइंड ऑफ अटैक
दैट इज एन एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी अटैक जिसमें
कि यूज़ एनtएलएम#श इंस्टीड ऑफ़ पासवर्ड।
इसमें एनtएलएम हैश का यूज़ किया जाता है।
पासवर्ड की जगह पे पास द हैश अटैक इज़ वन
ऑफ़ द मोस्ट डेंजरस एंड वेरी पॉपुलर अटैक
जिसको कि आप बड़े-बड़े सर्टिफिकेशंस के लिए
जरूर पढ़ेंगे। इसको पढ़ना ही पड़ेगा। तो आई
वुड रिक्वेस्ट एवरीबॉडी एज अ टास्क समझिए
कि ये जो अटैक्स यहां लिखे हैं इन अटैक्स
के बारे में थोड़ा आप खुद से एक्सप्लोर
कीजिएगा। थोड़ा खुद से भी पढ़िएगा। आपकी
क्लेरिटी और ज्यादा अच्छी हो जाएगी इन
अटैक्स को लेके। हालांकि एज एन एसओसी एल1
आपको इसमें एक्सपर्टीज नहीं होना है। आपको
इसकी टेक्निकल डिटेल में जाने की जरूरत
नहीं पड़ेगी। एल1 के तौर पे तो बिल्कुल
नहीं पड़ेगी। बट अगर आप जान जाएंगे थोड़ी
बहुत ओवरव्यू ले लेंगे तो इट विल बी
बेनिफिशियल। आपको पता रहेगा। नॉलेज तो कभी
भी बेकार नहीं होती ना। उसके बाद
करबरोसिंग स्टिल करबेरस सर्विस टिकट्स अब
टिकट ही चुरा लिया किसी का किसी और का
टिकट चुरा लिया वो एक चीज हो गई गोल्डन
टिकट फॉर फर्ज करबेरस टिकट्स टिकट्स को
फर्ज कर दिया यह गोल्डन टिकट अटैक हो गया
मतलब जो टिकट है उसको फर्ज करके डुप्लीकेट
करके वो हो गई आपकी डीसी सिंक स्टिल
पासवर्ड हैशेस फ्रॉम डीसी अब डोमेन
कंट्रोलर से पासवर्ड के हैश ही चुरा लिए
प्रिविलेज एस्क्लेशन यूजर एडेड टू डोमेन
एडमिनस अब डोमेन के एडमिनस उनमें नॉर्मल
एक मलेशियस अटैकर या मलेशियस यूजर को ऐड
कर दिया एज एन एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर इस तरह के
अटैक्स होते हैं। पासदा हैश हो गया, करब
रोस्टिंग हो गई, गोल्डन टिकट अटैक हो गया,
डीसी सिंक अटैक हो गया, प्रिविलेज
एस्क्लेशन अटैक हो गया। यह सारे अटैक्स
एक्टिव डायरेक्टरीज के ऊपर होते हैं।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] अब एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरी फॉर एसओसी अगर देखें तो इनके
कुछ एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी जो लॉग्स की हम बात
करें जो इंपॉर्टेंट है एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी
के लिए तो अगर मैं इवेंट आईडीज की बात
करूं तो 46242572
47204732
ये इंपॉर्टेंट एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी के लिए
इवेंट आईडीज हैं। जिसका मतलब है 4624
लॉगिन के लिए होता है। फेल लॉगिन के लिए
होता है। 2572 जो है एडमिन प्रिविलजेस के
लिए होता है। 4720 यूजर क्रिएट हुआ उसके
लिए 4732 यूजर एडेड टू ग्रुप ये तो आप
इवेंट आईडी और Windows इवेंट लॉग्स के जो
क्लासेस हुए उसमें मैंने ये सारी चीजें
बताई थी। दैट्स इट। तो ये इनके लिए
इंपॉर्टेंट है। अब
फाइनल [गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] एसओसी
माइंडसेट क्या होना चाहिए? जब आप
इन्वेस्टिगेट कर रहे हैं एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरी जैसी अटैक्स इसके ऊपर अटैक्स
के तो यह मत पूछिए कि व्हाट कमांड रन? कौन
सा कमांड रन हुआ है? आप यह पूछिए व्हाई
वाज़ इट रन? हु एग्जीक्यूटेड इट? व्हाट डड
इट एक्सेस? डड इट मूव लिटरली लैटरली? यह
आपको पूछना है कि भैया क्यों यह रन हुआ
है? किसने इसको रन किया है? क्या एक्सेस
किया गया इससे? एंड क्या लैटरल मूवमेंट
हुई है नेटवर्क के अंदर में? तो यह यू हैव
टू आस्क एज एन एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट। इस तरीके
का आपका माइंडसेट होना चाहिए। बीइंग एन
एसोसिएशन एनालिस्ट एल1। अब दिक्कत यहां पर
यह है कि एज एन एसोसिएट एनालिस्ट एलोवन
आपको एडी की बहुत डेप्थ में नहीं जाना
होता है। एक ओवरव्यू लेना है। मैंने आपको
जितना चीजें जितनी चीजें आपको यहां बताई
है ना उतनी चीजों की भी जरूरत नहीं है।
आपको ये करबस ऑथेंटिकेशन के डीप डीप डव
करना ही नहीं है। नहीं करना। मैं आपको यह
सब अपने तरफ से आपको बताता हूं। इस सीरीज
को इन सीरीज के इन क्लासेस को और भी
ज्यादा इंपैक्टफुल बनाने के लिए और भी
ज्यादा इस लेवल पर ले जाने के लिए कि लगे
कि आपको एक्चुअल लगे कि हां भाई यह पेड
ट्रेनिंग की तरह ही हमको पढ़ा रहे हैं।
उस लेवल पर लेकर जा सकता हूं। उस लेवल पर
ले जाने के लिए मैं यह चीजें आपको बताता
हूं ताकि आपको एक जेन्युइन चीजें आपको
मिले। जितनी चीजें आप एक्सपेक्ट करते हैं
उससे ज्यादा मिले। जितनी चीजें जरूरत हैं
उससे भी कुछ ज्यादा ही आपको मैं देकर
जाऊंगा पूरी ट्रेनिंग में। तो बेफिक्र
रहिए इस पूरे प्रोसेस को आपको मैंने समझा
दिया है। सिंपल सा कि डायरेक्टरी Windows
एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी क्या होता है? उसका
पूरा स्ट्रक्चर बता दिया है। इकोसिस्टम
समझा दिया है। पूरे लॉजिकल स्ट्रक्चर्स
में ऑब्जेक्ट ओयूज़ डोमेन ट्री फॉरेस्ट
डोमेन कंट्रोलर सब बता दिया मैंने आपको।
कैसे वर्क करते हैं। प्रोटोकॉल तीन डीएनएस
एलडप एंड करबोस यह सब बता दिया है। ग्रुप
पॉलिसीज के बारे में बता दी है सारी। टिकट
ग्रांटिंग टिकट टीजीटी और सेशन की क्या
होता है? वह बता दिया है। कैसे यह काम
करते हैं यह सब बता दिया है। पूरा करबरोस
ऑथेंटिकेशन कैसे काम करता है वह बता दिया
है। केडीसी की डिस्ट्रीब्यूशन सेंटर प्लस
ऑथेंटिकेशन सर्विस प्लस टिकट ग्रांटिंग
सर्विस इन सब के बारे में बता दिया। कवरेज
ऑथेंटिकेशन का हायरार्की बता दिया है पूरा
सब कुछ आपको यहां पे बता दिया है कैसे काम
करता है। उसके बाद किस तरीके से कौन-कौन
से स्टेप्स छह जो होते हैं उनको एग्जांपल
के थ्रू इजी वे में आपको समझा दिया है। छह
स्टेप्स सारे छह के छह स्टेप्स को कौन-कौन
से अटैक्स होते हैं एडी के ऊपर वो बता
दिया है और एसओसी की तरह आप कैसे इसको डील
करते हैं वो भी बता दिया है। दैट्स इट।
ठीक है? तो ये सारी चीजें क्लियर हो गई
है। और यहीं पे आपकी आज की क्लास समाप्त
होती है। दैट्स इट। आई होप कि आपको मजा
आया होगा। अब मैं आ जाता हूं यहां पे चैट
चैट ही चैट ही चैट पे। चैट ही चैट चैट पे
आ जाते हैं।
लाइक ठोक के जाना। हां सही बोला। लाइक ठोक
के जाना। जब भी जाओ लाइक ठोक के जाओ। मजा
आता है। ओके ओके
बिल्कुल बिल्कुल डीप में तो जाना ही है।
थैंक यू सर। बहुत अच्छा सेशन यो वेलकम
गौरव
नहीं आपको
प्रेम आपको एसओसी एल1 के लिए एल1 को वो
एल1 के उसमें नहीं आता वो ऑपरेशन में नहीं
आता एसओसी एल1 के एल एल1 के ऑपरेशन में वो
सब चीजें नहीं आती
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
टेक्निकली हो रहा है सब टेक्निकली हो रहा
है चलिए चलिए टॉप फैंस की लिस्ट एक बार
स्क्रॉल कर देता हूं। यहां पे ये स्क्रॉल
मैंने यहां पे कर दिया है। टॉप जो 50 की
लिस्ट होती है यहां पे। ये आप देख सकते
हैं यहां पे ऊपर से स्टार्टिंग से यहां पे
ये टॉप 50 की लिस्ट है। नाम मैं नहीं बोल
रहा हूं क्योंकि अब मैं एक दो का नाम बोल
के बाकी के छोड़ देता हूं। तो वो लोग
बोलते हैं सर मेरा नाम नहीं लिया। तो मैं
किसी का भी नाम नहीं ले रहा। बस यह मैं
आपको दिखा दे रहा हूं। दीज़ आर द टॉप 50
लिस्ट।
यह सारे हैं। दैट्स भूत बांग। यह तो अलग
ही नाम से आता है। भूत बांग
अजीबोगरीब नाम है। वाह यह पूरी की पूरी
आपकी लिस्ट है। आई होप कि यू एंजॉयड द
सेशन गाइस। आई होप
[गहरी सांस लेने की आवाज़]
मजा आया। ठोको लाइक ठोको लाइक। हां भाई
ठोको लाइक। लाइक कितने हो गए यार? लाइक का
पता नहीं चल पा रहा है मुझे। अच्छा हां इस
पे पता चल जाएगा ना लाइक कितने हो गए। 101
लाइक हो गए हैं। क्या बात है। अच्छी बात
है। 100 प्लस लाइक कर दिया आप लोगों ने।
अब कमेंट्स भी कर दिया करना। पिछले
वीडियोस जो पिछले लास्ट दो वीडियोस ये
क्लास 22 है। क्लास 21 और क्लास 20 के कम
वीडियोस में कमेंट्स अभी भी 100 प्लस नहीं
हुए हैं। तो प्लीज उसको आप कीजिए। दूसरी
चीज कि इस वीडियो पे भी कमेंट्स जरूर
कीजिएगा। 100 प्लस कमेंट्स एंड वी विल
ब्रिंगिंग द नेक्स्ट क्लास। लनिक्स खत्म
उसके बाद बच जाएगी प्रैक्टिकल और
डेमोंस्ट्रेशन वाली चीज पार्ट ओनली जो
उसके बाद आपका खत्म हो के एसओसी की पूरी
क्लासेस एंड सीरीज यह समाप्त हो जाएगी। सो
बहुत जल्द उसको भी हम कर देंगे। एंड आई
होप कि आपको मजा आ रहा है सेशन में। ठीक
है?
हैट्स ऑफ फ्रॉम नॉर्थ पोल कनाडा। थैंक्स
ब्रदर। थैंक यू वेरी मच। यस सर। मजा आ
गया।
सर सीरीज खत्म मत करो। बाद में इसको अपने
मेंबर्स के लिए पेड कर देना। अरे तो सीरीज
मतलब सीरीज तो खत्म ही हो जाएगी। वीडियोस
रहेंगी तो वह फिर बाद मेंबर ओनली हो सकते
हैं। कर सकते हैं। ठीक है गाइस? सो आज के
लिए बस इतना ही। आई होप यू एंजॉयड। प्लीज
शेयर द वीडियो टू दोज़ हु एक्चुअली नीड इट।
जिनको एक्चुअली ऐसे क्लासेस की नीड है
उनके साथ शेयर कीजिए। WhatsApp ग्रुप्स
में, Telegram ग्रुप्स में, अपने सोशल
प्रोफाइल्स पे, हैंडल्स पे, Telegram पे
एंड Lindin पे, Twitter पे हर जगह पे शेयर
कीजिए ताकि लोगों को पता चले इस सीरीज के
बारे में। दे गेट टू नो अबाउट दिस
पर्टिकुलर जॉब रेडी एसओसी एल वन फ्री
क्वालिटी लाइव ट्रेनिंग। थैंक यू सो मच
गाइस। मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट लाइव क्लास में।
बाय-ब एंड टेक केयर। ध्यान रखिए। मस्त मजे
में रहिए एंड मिलते हैं। ठीक है? बाय।